[Musique]
le week-end geoffroy deux frères animé
par leur passion pour l'eau ont décidé
d'emprunter les routes de la soie sur
les traces des premiers échanges entre
les civilisations
en quatre mois de la chine à paris il
parcourt sur leur side car plus de 15000
kilomètres à travers l'asie centrale et
l'asie mineure pour revivre l'évolution
du commerce mondial et son impact sur la
ressource en eau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue sur rt france
pour deux heures d'émission nous
décrypterons comme chaque soir du lundi
au jeudi
l'essentiel de l'information avec nos
invités en plateau et nos reporters sur
le terrain
voici les grands titres de l'actualité
de ce lundi 17 février le nouveau
ministre de la santé olivier verrons a
donné cet après midi le coup d'envoi
devant les députés des débats sur la
réforme des retraites vantant une
ambition immense un texte dénoncé
farouchement par les oppositions qui
critiquent également le départ d'agnès
buzyn il y avait notamment la charge de
ce dossier
c'est une première depuis huit ans
l'armée syrienne
notamment sur les dernières poches qui
était détenu par les djihadistes autour
d'alep
le président syrien bachar al-assad
s'engage à poursuivre l'offensive dans
le nord-ouest du pays pour libérer
l'ultime grand bastion tenu par les
djihadistes et les rebelles
deux navires déployés dans la zone à
l'est de la libye une décision de
l'union européenne à l'issue d'une
réunion du ministre des ministres des
affaires étrangères afin d'empêcher le
trafic d'armes le chef de la diplomatie
italienne luigi di maio précise que
cette mission navale sera arrêtée si
elle provoque un afflux de bateaux de
migrants
[Musique]
le nombre de contaminations coronavirus
s'élève à au moins 70 1540 chine et
environ 800 signalé dans une trentaine
d'autres pays les autorités chinoises
demande aux personnes guéries de donner
leur sang afin d'en extraire le plasma
pour soigner et mme hadad
[Musique]
vidéo avec des policiers diffusées sur
les réseaux sociaux elles sont de plus
en plus nombreux c'est à la demande des
syndicats que le ministre conduit une
étude juridique pour restreindre les
modalités de leur diffusion ça pose la
question de la sécurité des forces de
l'ordre fait il à rendre anonymes les
visages des policiers lors de la
diffusion de ces vidéos
où sont-elles au contraire un garde-fou
contre d'éventuelles bavures ce sera
l'objet de notre face à face ce soir
[Musique]
après dix jours en commission spéciale
les députés ont donc officiellement
commencé à débattre de la réforme des
retraites à l'assemblée nationale dans
une ambiance évidemment électrique
on retrouve tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial guillemin rossi bonsoir humain
vous êtes donc au coeur du palais
bourbon le nouveau ministre de la santé
a lancé les débats officiellement
oui bonsoir stéphanie et wiz son
intervention du nouveau ministre de la
santé à d'ailleurs fait beaucoup réagir
sur les bancs de l'opposition notamment
la référence à ambroise croizat l'un des
pères de la sécurité sociale comme vous
pouvez l'imaginer le président de la
chambre a même dû rappeler à l'ordre
cette opposition quelques minutes
seulement après le début du discours du
nouveau ministre de la santé
regarder devant vous et continuez
monsieur le ministre a encouragé richard
ferrand alors que l'expression du
mécontentement du côté de la france
insoumise couvrait la voie du
successeurs d'agnès buzyn je vous
propose d'ailleurs d'écouter un extrait
du discours du nouveau ministre de la
santé olivier vers ont écouté le système
actuel à bien des qualités nous ne
manquons jamais de le rappeler est la
première d'entre elles est celle d'un
système qui fonctionne par répartition
mais il a aussi des défauts et ce sont
ses défauts que nous devons corriger le
premier c'est d'être d'une telle
complexité qu'il en devient
incompréhensible et qui ne suscite pas à
la confiance notamment pour les plus
jeunes
je pars mire du système actuel mesdames
et messieurs les députés
yooz met trente neuf ans j'ai déjà
cotisé à quatre régimes de retraite ce
différend s'il vous plaît mais chacun
sait aussi que le système actuel est
injuste pour beaucoup de concitoyens
je pense aux femmes et à tous ceux
nombreux pour qui la vie professionnelle
n'a jamais été un long fleuve tranquille
l'ambition que porte le gouvernement est
triple construire un système universel
qui assure chaque français et où tout le
monde doit être assurée quel que soit
son parcours et quelle que soit sa
position prendre en compte les
trajectoires de vie en déplaçant notre
regard du statut vers l'activité et
enfin ce système doit mobiliser de
nouveaux leviers comme la prévention ou
le droit à la reconversion pour les
métiers les plus pénibles parce que oui
il faut le dire le système actuel laisse
au bord du chemin les plus fragiles de
nos concitoyens les moins représentées
il attend souvent trop longtemps pour
réparer au lieu de prévenir
suite à cette intervention et à celle
d'autres membres du gouvernement il y a
eu les examens par les députés de deux
motion de rejet préalable l'un pour le
projet de loi ordinaire déposée par le
parti communiste l'autre pour le projet
de loi organique cette fois-ci déposés
par les républicains alors une motion de
rejet préalable qu'est ce que c'est
c'est tout simplement
cela permet tout simplement de faire
reconnaître que l'une ou plusieurs des
dispositions d'un texte est
inconstitutionnelle et donc d'annuler
totalement les débats il y a eu ensuite
l'examen d'une motion référendaire là
encore déposée par le parti communiste
alors une vraie motion référendaire
lorsqu'elle est signée par 10 % des
députés qu'elle est adoptée par
l'assemblée nationale permet de demander
au président de la république
d'organiser un référendum
alors bien sûr toutes ces motions ont
été rejetées scène laisser ça ne faisait
aucun doute l'issue des votes ne faisait
guère de doute mais en réalité tout ceci
fait partie d'une stratégie de
l'opposition d'abord gagner du temps et
ensuite se faire entendre il y a
également une autre stratégie
l'obstruction parlementaire
quarante mille deux cent soixante dix
sept amendements très exactement ont été
déposées pour l'examen de ce texte de la
réforme des retraites
le vote final doit avoir lieu en théorie
le 3 mars prochain
mais les délais il y a peu de chances
que les délais soient tenus car la tâche
pour les députés en réalité est colossal
encore une fois plus de 40 mille
amendements cela fait presque deux mille
sept cents amendements par jour à
examiner donc l'assemblée nationale fait
à nouveau face à une obstruction
parlementaire comme l'a dit richard
ferrand ce sont des heures des jours et
des nuits de débats qui attendent les
députés ici au palais bourbon
merci guy marrot signé pour nicolas
dupont aignan l'opposition à l'assemblée
nationale cherche alerter les français
sur le caractère néfaste de cette mesure
mais tout simplement alerter les
français sur le drame de cette pension
de retraite
vraiment vous savez cette réforme va
faire baisser les futurs pensionnés les
jeunes d'au moins entre 10 et 20% leur
pension de retraite c'est considérable
et quel est le moyen que nous avons si
ce n'est d'alerter l'opinion est alerté
les parlementaires sur leurs
responsabilités c'est la porte ouverte à
terme à une telle baisse des pensions de
retraite qu'il y aura une capitalisation
c'est à dire une obligation de prendre
des plans d'épargné retraite d'ailleurs
axa a commencé à faire une publicité les
compagnies d'assurances nous font des
publicités pour dire avec le système à
points vos pensions vont baisser
tout le monde le sait et donc il faut
compléter donc c'est la fin de l'égalité
entre les français
donc ça dépasse le clivage droite gauche
ces considérations ne se produire et ici
nous allons résister face à un pouvoir
qui est d'un cynisme absolu et une
journée symbolique pour les opposants à
ce projet de loi et se sont mobilisés
encore une fois dans la capitale
la direction justement l'assemblée
nationale un dispositif important de
forces de l'ordre était déployé
les précisions de notre reporter katia
pique nique
[Applaudissements]
alors que le texte de réforme des
retraites entrés aujourd'hui à
l'assemblée
mon mobilisation était au rendez-vous ce
17 février
le lieu était l'opéra l'opéra de paris
ou de nombreuses mobilisations avaient
eu lieu ces derniers temps
eh bien aujourd'hui c'est au tour des
syndicats est fou au sud et solidaires
d'appeler au rassemblement il y avait
également des coordinations étudiantes
des gilet jaune
des représentants de nombreuses
professions environ 2000 personnes qui
se sont dirigés vers l'assemblée
nationale juste avant d'arriver place du
palais bourbon
ils ont été contenus par des forces de
l'ordre alors il ya eu même des charges
des lacrymogènes interpellation au moins
mais la situation est très vite redevenu
vraiment calme pour l'anecdote le gilet
jaune avait été interdit de certains
périmètres durant ces dernières semaines
par ces derniers mois notamment
l'assemblée nationale eh bien
aujourd'hui ils ont pu y aller et tout
ce rassemblement s'est mué en grande
agora politique et citoyenne et
militante
il y avait d'ailleurs par exemple des
militants d'extinction rébellion et de
nombreux leaders politiques des députés
même des sénateurs la sénatrice esther
benbassa d'europe écologie les verts ces
personnes ont pris la parole ils ont
harangué les foules
je vous proposais le député olivier
besancenot le fondateur du npa ainsi que
eric coquerel député la france a sonné
conscient que c'est pas l'intérêt du
parlement que les choses vont se passer
mais à l'extérieur et c'est pour ça
qu'on est venu simplement
d'abord se rappeler au bon souvenir de
l'assemblée nationale de leur député
pour dire qu on les oubliera pas et
n'oubliera pas qu'ils comptent voter
quoi et dire à travers eux que à
emmanuel macron que nous va pas lâcher
la faire avec le mouvement druze
mouvement de grève demeure de
manifestations mobilisations
il doit continuer ce sera la seule issue
pour gagner maintenant on est condamné à
à tous taper sur le même clou parce que
si on tape à tous sur le même clou on
n'y arrivera jamais donc que ça soit par
une manifestation nationale la
généralisation de la grève on a besoin
de replanter dans le décor le fait qu'on
n'est pas des rigolos et qu' on n'a pas
fait tout ce qu'on a fait depuis le 5
décembre simplement pour gagner la
bataille des idées aux logos dans
l'hémicycle c'est sur la même chose hier
on a des des ministres qui nous font du
discours à la orwell en permanence
d'accord qui nous explique ce serait une
loi de protection sociale de justice
sociale certains ont même acquis au même
parler de démocratie sociale c'est ça
qui est le plus insupportable
ils sont en train de démanteler un des
piliers du patrimoine social français et
ils font mine de quelque part vouloir en
réalité du progrès alors qu'ils ne font
que reculer l'âge de la départ après
attaquer les pensions sans aucune
légitimité
donc je peux vous dire je pense que dans
l'assemblée ça va ça va être assez chaud
pendant plusieurs semaines même s'il n'y
avait pas des dizaines de milliers de
militants aujourd'hui la mobilisation
était vraiment tout à fait symbolique
vous voyez que les politiques les
citoyens les militants souhaitent faire
tout ce qui est en leur pouvoir pour
faire reculer cette réforme des
retraites
et sachant qu'il y ait une nouvelle
mobilisation le 20 février pour en
parler nous sommes sur ce plateau avec
hugo dudouit aides soignants urgences de
l'hôpital ambroise paré membres du
collectif inter urgence bonsoir d'abord
d'être avec nous et hugo dudouit à ses
côtés axel sabban avocat fiscaliste à
paris bon soir alors vous aussi merci
d'être là donc le débat à l'assemblée un
qu'on attendait ça y est c'est enclenché
le gouvernement qui table toujours sur
une adoption en première lecture avant
les élections municipales dans un mois
espère même un feu vert définitif d'ici
dd ça d'ici l'été ça vous semble
possible mettre ça dans les délais me
semble extrêmement compliqué à tenir
quand on voit le nombre d'amendements
qui ont été déposées
en vue de l'examen en séance donc étant
donné que la commission n'a pas pu
prendre examiné l'intégralité des
amendements qui avaient été déposés par
les députés
ils doivent en principe reprendre
l'examen du texte à 0 évidemment ils
partent du des travaux de la commission
il n'empêche que il ya quarante et un
mille amendements qui ont été déposés
dans le cadre de cet examen en séance
ça me paraît très compliqué de tenir les
délais du gouvernement qui l'idée de
mémoire sont fixées au 3 mars pour pour
l'adoption en première lecture
sauf si les députés décident d'avoir des
journées je ne sais pas où ils vont
trouver les heures nécessaires à
l'examen de tous ses amendements et du
texte en général
alors je m'adresse à la fois aux
juristes donc le professionnel du droit
mais aussi aux combattants farouche de
cette réforme on va en parler est ce que
vous vous parleriez d'obstruction
parlementaire comme certains opposants
aujourd'hui alors ya une volonté
d'obstruction parlementaire qui est
assumé par les députés notamment les
députés de la france insoumise et les
députés du parti communiste mais il faut
savoir que cette volonté de trucs qu'on
parte parlementaire assumer elle se fait
en réaction à ce qu'ils considéraient
comme une obstruction parlementaire mais
de la part du gouvernement
en soumettant l'examen d'un texte majeur
de ce quinquennat peut-être le texte
majeur de ce quinquennat à des délais de
débat aussi court et surtout à des
textes aujourd'hui qui est qui comporte
une part d'imprécisions qui est très
importante avec une étude d'impact très
volumineuse que les déplier n'ont pas
forcément le temps d'un gérer en
intégralité
et tout cela dans un temps extrêmement
court donc obstruction je pense qu'il y
est il est difficile de contester
l'existence d'une obstruction
après savoir si elle est légitime on pas
je me garde le jugement là dessus mais
en tout cas c'est ce que le député
avance alors on a du mal à savoir
comment ça va se passer parce que le
président de l'assemblée un richard
ferrand proposé sans succès un gros
politique de l'unité à senteur sur trois
semaines
une réaction est ce que
ça va s'embourber finalement ces débats
sans fin il ya un risque de cela je
pense qu'il ya un risque énorme de toute
façon à vouloir laisser un temps
déterminé à l'examen d'une réforme de
cette ampleur
après que ce soit sans heurt 200 plus
non vraiment à mon sens une réforme
aussi importante sur la l'organisation
de notre société notre vision de la
solidarité intergénérationnelle
cela mérite d'y consacrer le temps qu'il
faut les députés là dessus doivent à
pouvoir examiner sereinement le texte
s'il décide de son besoin d'examiner le
texte
jusqu'à cet été ou après il faut leur
laisser le temps nécessaire pour le
faire on va reparler encore avec vous
hugo dudouit vous vous êtes aide
soignant on l'a dit vous vous l'avez
trouvé comment votre nouveau ministre
celui à qui vous allez avoir à faire
beaucoup ces prochains temps sur veyrenc
il ya donc lancé aujourd'hui cette
réforme est ce qu'il vous a fait plutôt
bonne impression alors je ne sais pas si
je peux dire qu'il a fait bonne
impression a tant donné déjà ce que les
musées a pu faire avant on va en parler
un évidement tout à l'heure dans un
deuxième temps il a décidé de lancer une
enquête auprès des soignants pour
connaître nos
les difficultés au niveau du travail ça
ne servira à rien parce que ça fait onze
mois qu'on lui rabâche que le crie haut
et fort que ça va pas et c'est pareil
qu'une enquête que ça va changer grand
chose
alors oui neurologue à l'instar brrr
agnès buzyn était évidemment aux
médecins spécialistes également c'est un
neurologue qu'est ce que c'est de nature
tout de même à vous rassurer cette
connaissance du terrain du nouveau
ministre est ce que vous êtes prêtre
quand même à vous lui à lui laisser une
chance alors à lui laisser une chance
oui alors après à faire confiance je
sais pas parce que agnès buzyn est aussi
médecin et on voit ce que ça a donné
et également un médecin n'en faudra je
pense laisser quelques semaines pour
voir ce qu'ils proposent
on va en parler de toutes façons
effectivement de ce remplacement dans un
deuxième temps ça te passation de
pouvoir qui a eu lieu aujourd'hui sur le
dossier des retraites vous quelle est
votre réaction on a vu de nouvelles
manifestations aujourd'hui plutôt
symbolique ces débats qu'il commence à
l'assemblée nationale est ce que vous en
attendez quelque chose vous dans votre
profession
alors moi j'ai 20 ans donc les retraites
cédant très longtemps encore vous y
pensez quand même on part ça vous étonne
justement ces grandes manifestations
cette résistance c'est intéressant vous
poser la question qu'est ce que vous
avez 20 ans justement alors c'est pas
que ça m'étonne je pense que c'est bien
c'est bien qu'on se défende pour notre
avenir notre soir après le travail et
j'espère contre le temps ça sort a
évolué parce que moi je suis quand même
parti pour être aides-soignants ou
infirmer peu importe son dévolu sur mon
travail - jusqu'à 65 ans donc c'est bien
connu mais est né est-ce que c'est mes
aînés se bat et que les jeunes suivent
le mouvement aussi ce serait pas mal
alors axel sabban vous avez assisté à
une assemblée générale extraordinaire au
barreau de paris la semaine dernière
vous avez fait vous même différentes
propositions pour essayer vraiment de de
bloquer cette réforme qu'est ce qui en
est ressorti est ce qu'il ya des
propositions qui ont été retenues est ce
que vous allez vous renouveler dans
votre mouvement de contestation ce
projet alors déjà la poursuite de la
grève a été votée par l'assemblée
générale du barreau de paris la première
qui a intervenu depuis 1990 c'est quand
même un fait notable qui démontre la
mobilisation des avocats et la
contestation autour de cette réforme des
retraites le les propositions qui ont
été faites et ça c'est le côté que je
regrette un peu en fait
intéresse essentiellement une poursuite
de la grève par les avocats plaidants on
ne reproche beaucoup aux avocats des
cabinets d'ie d'affaires de ne pas
montrer de solidarité à l'égard de la
profession en général
pour ma part j'estime que ce manque de
solidarité ne naît pas on peut pas dire
qu'on manque de solidarité c'est juste
que des avocats d'affaires n'ont pas
forcément la possibilité de d'exercer
leur des actions de la main
de la même manière que les avocats
plaidants c'est exactement pour cela en
fait que je propose est une modalité
d'action un peu de nouvelles à savoir
mettre à disposition du barreau de paris
et des barreaux de france un modèle
standard de réclamations contentieuses
permettant à chaque avocat à chaque
citoyen aussi aux avocats qui pourrait
du coup solliciter leurs familles et
leurs proches
si je vais visant ce modèle de
réclamation permettrait en fait de
contester sur le principe l'imposition
qui a été due au titre des revenus des
années précédentes mais aussi de la taxe
foncière taxe d'habitation
on peut imaginer tout contester l'idée
naît l'idée n'est pas forcément
d'obtenir des dégrèvements d'impôts car
cela ce modèle serait standard et il
n'aurait pas de réalité sur le fond en
fait ce qui la proposition visait
essentiellement à demander aux
contribuables aux citoyens de se
mobiliser massivement pour saturer les
services de contrôle des administrations
fiscales paralysées des services de
contrôle
or les services de contrôle c'est ce qui
permet à l'état d'assurer le
recouvrement en tout cas d'assurer que
le les impositions sont correctement
recouvrer donc
donc en fait attaqué l'état sur le
budget aujourd'hui le budget c'est quand
même le le mot qui est sur toutes les
lèvres au sommet de l'état il me
semblait que attaquer l'état sur cette
question pouvaient présenter un certain
intérêt
surtout que les avocats d'affaires
pouvaient participer de cette manière à
cette contestation contre la réforme des
retraites
alors pour répondre notamment à votre
grogne un celle des avocats les députés
ont voté aussi aujourd'hui en faveur
d'un abattement sur les cotisations des
professions indépendantes est ce que
quand même c'est de nature un petit peu
à vous rassurer
non pas du tout alors ça limite l'impact
de la hausse des cotisations serait
avocats les plus les plus précaires
cependant cet abattement ne permet pas
de gommer en intégralité la hausse des
cotisations
or on voit que cette réforme des
retraites elle va impacter
essentiellement les avocats qui se
charge des missions les plus cruciales à
la nôtre notre justice ce sont les paies
des avocats qui sont en charge de
missions d'être juridictionnelle dont
qui est ce qu'ils exercent des missions
à destination des justiciables les plus
fragiles or ces avocats risquent d'être
pénalisés financièrement par cette
réforme des retraites est ainsi cela
pourrait induire une un nombre d'avocats
qui fonde en liquidation judiciaire par
exemple bref d un nombre d'avocats moins
important et donc un accès à la justice
plus compliqué pour les contribuables je
pense qu'on a les mêmes problématiques
au niveau de l'hôpital public en fait
c'est fragiliser l'accès à la justice
donc peut-être dans les zones les plus
tendues ne plus avoir d'avocat pour
permettre de faire valoir ses droits
pour l'hôpital public ne plus avoir de
deux cliniques de maternité de et
obliger les gens à l'hôpital aux
urgences en sachant qu'un hormis c'est
un chiffre 40 % de patients qui n'ont
rien à faire aux urgences qui pourrait
très bien consulté un médecin
généraliste
on va en parler justement avec vous on y
vient rester avec nous messieurs olivier
verrons
donc d'être nommé rapporteur il venait
d'être nommé rapporteur du volet
organique de cette réforme des retraites
il prend donc désormais la casquette de
ministre de la santé la passation de
pouvoir s'est déroulée ce matin avec
agnès buzyn ce médecin neurologue jusque
va débuter la république en marge de
l'isère occupée depuis deux ans et demi
le poste de rapporteur général de la
commission des affaires sociales agnès
buzyn donc démissionné hier de ses
fonctions pour se lancer dans la
bataille des municipales parisiennes en
remplacement évidemment de l'eau
benjamin griveaux on écoute
mesdames et messieurs c'est avec une
grande émotion que je quitte ce
ministère est évident avec la cité pour
mener la campagne des élections
municipales à paris
j'ai remis hier soir ma démission au
premier ministre et au président de la
république quitte et solistes heures
vous l'imaginez c'est un déchirement
pendant plus de deux ans et demi j'ai
l'honneur de conduire les politiques de
santé et les politiques sociales
démocrates et les droits légaux des lui
je me tourne maintenant vraiment vers
vous agnès buzyn très ému qui dit au
revoir un ministère déjà votre réaction
j'imagine que vous avez beaucoup
échanger avec vous vos collègues c'est
un regret c'est un soulagement ça laisse
la porte ouverte à peut-être de
nouvelles espérances pour vous alors en
premier lieu un dégoût moi
personnellement j'ai après onze mois de
mobilisation elle quitte le bateau winmo
pour le moment la crise hôpitaux la
craie des urgences le coronavirus qui
est une crise sanitaire dont qu'elle
abandonne ses dossiers au profit d'une
campagne municipale ont compressé
certainement d'un plan personnel alors
on peut pas la juger en soit c
peut-être pas elle qui a décidé de
directement démissionner on état
d'émotion on peut se poser est
effectivement la question est-ce qu'elle
a choisie ou en tout cas lui a proposé
fortement en tous cas pour vous c'est
clairement un abandon de poste avec des
dossiers qui sont très lourd et très
important évidemment pour vous et pour
le pays c'est ça parce que l'association
l'hôpital public a eu pas mal ça fait
onze mois qu'on le dise même des années
que c'est dit et l'arrivée du nouveau
ministre va pas je pense changer grand
chose à la situation
après trois cent mille signatures d'une
pétition des manifestations répétées et
plein d'autres types d'actions on est
toujours au point zéro
on n'avance pas pour vous est-ce qu'il
ya un bilan qui est totalement négatif
de la part de la ministre busin où il y
a quand même eu des choses à son crédit
totalement négatif sur moi qui ai je ne
serais donc plus deux ans je n'ai rien
vu de positif en deux ans on m'a vendu
du rêve quand j'ai commencé à travailler
c'est du rêve parce qu'elle du travail
d'équipé c'est très beau c'est le mi6
finance un des plus beaux métiers du
monde
mais au niveau de tout ce qui est autour
c'est très moche j'employais justement
le terme de soulagement parce que j'ai
anticipé cette réponse rien de positif
pour vous on peut comprendre qu' il y
ait effectivement une peut-être le
sentiment d'être méprisés quand un
ministre pas sur un gros dossier mais
est ce que justement vous n'avez pas
l'espoir que ça ouvre la porte
peut-être à d'autres propositions avec
olivier ferrand alors je pense un léger
soulagement quand même avec un petit un
flan vent nouveau
faudra voir dans les semaines à venir ce
qui lui proposera son quel plan il va se
baser nous ce qui est sûr c'est qu'on va
pas lui et ses deux cadeaux ça fait trop
longtemps qu'on attendait revendications
et
et que nos revendications soient
entendues et il a commencé par dire
qu'il était qu'ils n'auraient pas tour
de chauffe qu'il était connaissez les
dossiers qu'ils étaient prêts à partir
alors on l'attend on va voir je peux
comprendre votre votre colère face à aux
départ d'agnès buts et en fait on est
confronté aujourd'hui
enfin le ministère de la santé est
confronté à une triple crise donc la
crise sociétale avec la réforme des
retraites la crise institutionnelle de
la crise de l'hôpital et une crise
sanitaire avec le coronavirus on a une
ministre qui pas faire des municipales à
paris donc qui n'est absolument pas
préparé pour cette cet enjeu des
municipales mais quel message que cela
envoie au fond c'est qu'un ministre peut
être parfaitement remplacé sur des
sujets extrêmement technique qui soulève
énormément de grogne parmi nos citoyens
mais en fait est-ce que ce ministre là
est vraiment porteur d'un message
personnel d'une d'une touche personnelle
sur les réformes
ou alors c'est juste un produit
politique qui remplaçables à volonté car
de toute façon les orientations
techniques sont décidés autres parents
on peut se poser la question de la
pertinence de l'identité du ministre de
la santé en fait aujourd'hui si on peut
remplacer n'importe quelle politique
d'un claquement de doigts c'est beaucoup
trop facile et ça permet de justifier
largement la colère de personnes qui
sont placés sous la tutelle de ce
ministère et goodwill risquent d'être
ici un bouc émissaire du gouvernement
si jamais elle rate aux municipales on
dira que voilà c'était toute sa faute
merci en tout cas à tous les deux accès
l'aca bango déduit d'avoir été
avec nous merci à vous dans quelques
instants rester avec nous nous parlerons
de la syrie où les forces
gouvernementales ont repris autour de
l'épreuve des poches contrôlées par des
groupes islamistes
et puis direction également la libye
nouvelle mission navale va être déployée
par l'union européenne pour empêcher les
livraisons d'armes
[Musique]
que veut-il dire en japonais et qui
comme henry alors il veut dire qui ne
sort pas de chez soi tout simplement le
propre du phénomène hikikomori c'est que
on trouve des jeunes au japon qui refuse
de sortir de chez eux alors qu'eux ils
n'ont pas de pathologie identifiée dans
la nomenclature psychiatriques
aujourd'hui l'équipe et maury ne sont
pas des fadas de jeux vidéo c'est pas
des gens qui passent tout leur temps
dans leur chambre scotché à l'ordinateur
à jouer aux jeux vidéo et c'est un
documentaire qui permet de comprendre en
quoi ce phénomène est vraiment
spécifique de la culture japonaise au
japon la pression scolaire est
extrêmement forte
mais les parents s'endettent souvent à
vie pour que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis vous savez au moment de
la crise d'adolescence un bel quelque
chose qui est remis en question
c'est une super méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie au japon j'ai été
frappé par le cancer il ya environ 55
ans et sept mois et je me suis dit
autrefois on utilisait la danse comme
thérapie alors j'ai décidé de danser
le résultat est que je suis ici
aujourd'hui je venais d'avoir un
accident où j'avais cru mourir ce cas
pareils je sens que j'ai le souffle
épique vous pouvez pas dire non je suis
si malheureux ça ne marche pas j'avais
eu le sentiment que mon corps ma ville
trahi
j'ai commencé à danser la danse de mon
âme et la danse de mon désespoir alors à
m soro et je serais heureuse d'avoir
trouver où il fallait dans ce fait pour
tout le monde et pour la vie ici on
l'appelle la tour de david et pour
beaucoup de gens c'est l'endroit le plus
sûr de la capitale du venezuela
pourtant célèbre pour des taux de
criminalité urbaine très élevé
2500 personnes sans abri ont occupé ce
gratte-ciel inachevé du centre de
caracas
ils en ont chassé les criminels et
organiser leur propre coopérative
d'habitation
[Musique]
il
comme on pas que ces deux noms évoquent
pas seulement le cinéma
ils sont le cinéma
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
charles pathé a le génie des affaires
léon gaumont est un ingénieur surdoué
ces deux hommes que tout oppose et se
sont forgé une destinée commune dans une
perpétuelle surenchère ils ont bâti
chacun leur empire et dominer le monde
[Musique]
et
20h30 merci de nous rejoindre en direct
sur rt france c'est une première depuis
huit ans l'armée syrienne donc mis la
main sur les dernières poches qui était
détenu par les djihadistes autour d'alep
est d'après l'agent sanaa les
combattants auraient quitté leur avant
poste à l'ouest et au nord de la ville
direction la frontière turque et
précision de rania berrada ce n'était
pas arrivé depuis 2012 l'armée syrienne
vient de reprendre le contrôle de 28
poche jusque-là aux mains des groupes
islamistes en banlieue d'alep annonce de
l'agencé de presse publique syrienne
sana
dans une allocution le porte-parole de
l'armée syrienne s'est félicité du
succès de l'opération et l'arabie et
sourit les héros de l'armée arabe
syrienne ont poursuivi leur avancée
déterminé à déraciner le terrorisme des
mécréants et à chasser les tueurs armés
qui voulaient confisquer la volonté de
notre peuple dans la région il les
prenait en otage et les utiliser comme
des boucliers humains afin d'entraver
l'avancée de l'armée et de retarder la
fin de ces factions armées qui sont des
factions terroristes selon le droit
international
nos braves soldats ont un conflit leur
mission avec une grande efficacité et en
un temps record des dizaines de villages
et de villes sont de nouveau sous le
contrôle du gouvernement
à l'ouest et au nord-ouest d'athènes
[Musique]
toujours selon lagence sanaa les
combattants djihadistes se sont retirés
de leurs avants postes vers la frontière
turque
il laisse ainsi la totalité de la
périphérie d'alep aux mains des forces
de bachar el-assad une route stratégique
reliant damas et alep avec ses centres
industriels a également été reprise aux
rebelles dimanche soir à l'annoncé de ce
succès militaires des scènes de liesse
ont éclaté dans la ville les habitants
d'alep se dit
soulagée du départ des groupes
jihadistes c'est grâce à dieu grâce à
nos prières grâce à l'armée arabe
syrienne
que dieu les protège et face qu'ils
retrouvent leur famille vous êtes la
meilleure armée du monde
vous avez mis à genoux les états unis
vous avez mis à genoux les turcs et tous
les envahisseurs et nous sommes fiers de
vous vous êtes la syrie vous avez appris
au monde le sens du mot liberté
le président syrien bachar al assad
s'est engagé ce lundi à poursuivre
l'offensive dans le nord-ouest du pays
pour libérer l'ultime grand bastion tenu
par les djihadistes une déclaration qui
intervient alors que louer nu réitère
ses appels pour un cessez le feu dans la
région d'idlib
selon les nations unies dans cette zone
les combats et frappes aériennes ont
fait plus de 900 mille déplacés depuis
décembre et pour en parler nous sommes
avec aden un mohammedi chercheur en
géopolitique bonsoir avec moi mais dis
merci d'être avec nous les troupes du
président bachar qui ont repris le
contrôle de la ceinture de localités
entourant la ville d'alep
quelle est la portée déjà de cette
information
il ya une portée stratégique avec la
reprise de comme le signalait votre
votre collègue delà de l'autoroute 25
entre l'autoroute qui relie damas à alep
et il ya une portée aussi symbolique
c'est à dire la reconquête du nord ouest
se poursuit en dépit des objections aux
turcs
c'est une étape décisive selon vous oui
parce que de toutes les manières sachant
qu' il ya encore une présence américaine
résiduelles au nord-est du pays le nord
ouest
aujourd'hui est l'ultime poche rebelle
l'ultime page jihadistes pour le
l'ultime poche de djihadistes qui
comment dire qu'ils résistent encore à
la reconquête uriel c'est alors la
recontre loyalistes est menée par d'un
côté l'armée syrienne et de l'autre par
l'armée russe qui a soutenu largement
cette reconquête notamment sur le plan
aérien
alors le président bachar qui s'est
engagé aujourd'hui justement poursuivre
cette offensive dans le nord-ouest du
pays pour je cite libéré l'ultime grand
bastion tenu par les djihadistes et les
rebelles est ce qui a encore beaucoup de
travail parce que
ça va durer longtemps oui alors là la
région d'alep a été libéré la ville
d'alep est libérée depuis la fin d'année
le principal noeud aujourd'hui pour la
reconquête loyalistes c'est la région
d'idleb
et c'est la ville d'idleb alors d'autant
que dans la ville d'idleb on a affaire à
un groupe djihadiste qui s'est montré
efficace d'un point de vue militaire
jusque là je pense à tahrir le cheikh
donc cette organisation issue d'al qaïda
même si le lien aujourd'hui n'est plus
revendiquer donc oui alors il ya ce
n'est évidemment ce ne j'ai envie de
dire opérationnel militaire il ya aussi
le noeud diplomatique politique c'est la
position de la turquie parce que la
turquie ne soutient pas le seul groupe
djihadiste ne veut pas d'une poursuite
de cette reconquête urria liste pour des
raisons
j'en veux dire à la fois géopolitique
parce qu'elle veut se laisser une zone
tampon pour ces pour ses protégés et
pour des raisons humanitaires parce que
la turquie c'est risque un nouvel afflux
de réfugiés en cas de poursuite de la
reconquête loyalistes évidemment en face
les arguments des russes et du pouvoir
syrien sont là qu'on reproche à la
turquie de ne pas avoir sécurisé de ne
pas avoir parti de ne pas avoir sécurisé
une zone qu'elle était censée en partie
sécurisée je pense aux accords de sotchi
de septembre 2018
et lors de ces accords la turquie était
quand même censé sécuriser notamment
cette autoroute comme ça elle ne l'a pas
fait le cessez le feu
pas respectés par respecter sachant en
plus que les protégés de la turquie
c'est à dire ce qu'on appelait ce qu'on
appelle l'armée nationale syrienne ce
qu'on appelait le front national de
libération
7 les protégés de la turquie ont perdu
face au destin c'est ça aussi il ne faut
pas l'oublier ça que c'est aussi parce
que les groupes jihadistes ont pris le
pouvoir dans cette zone ont pris le
pouvoir à idleb qu'on a qu'on a affaire
à 7 à cette situation particulièrement
difficile et l'autre grande difficulté
pour moi c'est peut-être la principale
difficulté c'est que contrairement aux
précédentes reconquête
qu'il s'agisse d'alep des rares le sud
de la haute à damas il n'y a plus de
zone de repli c'est à dire que les
groupes rebelles qu'on a viré par
exemple de dollars sont sortis de
derrière avec des accords de
cessez-le-feu négocié avec la russie et
se sont retrouvés aujourd'hui à idleb
après il n ya plus rien et plus on va
pas leur proposer une nouvelle un
nouveau refuge donc c'est une difficulté
aux essais apprenant montre comment
peut-on en sortir désormais je pense
qu'il faudra encore attendre la
l'armée syrienne a bien avancé dans la
région d'alep il y a une dizaine de
jours l'armée syrienne a fait une
avancée majeure dans la province d'idleb
je pense notamment à une ville qui
faisait la jonction entre les deux
principales art
les deux principales routes de la région
les autoroutes comme 4,25
l'un je pense qu'ils sont en train de se
calmer il est si on réfléchit un peu à
cette scion si on repense un peu ou pas
ces deux sets avant cette offensive
loyalistes dans la région
on se rend compte que elle se fait par
à-coups ses terres que la russie veille
au grain elle ne veut pas d'une
offensive loyalistes total tout
simplement parce que la turquie
brandy brandit sa ligne rouge et donc je
pense que là il ya en ce moment des
négociations entre la russie et la
turquie justement ou à au sujet d'idleb
je pense qu'il y ait dans les prochaines
semaines il va y avoir un petit
ralentissement des dauphins du gloria
liste autre symbole l'aéroport des
lettres qui va rouvrir aux vols
commerciaux c'est une première depuis
bien longtemps depuis 2012
qu'est ce que ça dit sachant que les
pédants des poumons économique
évidemment allait péter était la
capitale
du nord du pays c'était une terre grands
pôles industriels c'est peut-être l'un
des principaux pôles industriels de la
région depuis la guerre c'est une ville
qui a été fragilisée affaibli donc
l'objectif de l'aciérie et de sons de
son partenaire russe c'est de relancer
l'activité économique dans la région
parce que l'obsession aujourd'hui de
moscou avant même la reconstruction
politique avant même de poursuivre les
travaux d'astana c'est la reconstruction
matérielle et qui dit reconstruction
matérielle des activités économiques
donc de ce point de vue c'est une
victoire assez importante effectivement
est la reconstruction oui parce que 900
mille déplacés depuis décembre selon les
chiffres donnés par l'onu dans le nord
ouest syrien qu'est-ce que vous évoque
ces chiffres c'est une catastrophe
humanitaire à ceux qui nous ont fait
j'allais dire qui ne dit pas son nom
mais si mais je pense que les russes ont
réussi un peu cet exploit jeudi entre
guillemets de façon un peu un peu
cynique de comment dire de détaler la
catastrophe humanitaire
donc elle ne soit pas aussi visible qu'à
l'époque de l'attak de l'offensive daley
à la fin de l'année 2016 en fait on a d
une catastrophe humanitaire parakou où
kiné qui est beaucoup moins médiatisé
par exemple qu'à l'époque d'afrique pour
le pour la population aux kurdes aussi
parce que ils l'aiment
ce site beaucoup moins d'émotion parce
que c'est une ville contrôlée par des
djihadistes universellement considérée
comme des terroristes on n'a pas affaire
à des rebelles ou à des modérés ce sont
des djihadistes et aux nations-unies
sont considérés comme des terroristes
donc oui
et je pense que la russie qui se
préoccupe beaucoup plus de sons de sa
réputation quelle époque beaucoup des
buts sur l'intervention entre 2015 et
2016 la russie pouvait se permettre de
tourner le dos aux commentaires au
regard aujourd'hui maintenant que la
russie à gagner militairement sur le sol
syrien la russie se préoccupe de sa
réputation de son image et donc veut
éviter les catastrophes humanitaires
d'ailleurs la russie a ouvert un certain
nombre de couloirs
aujourd'hui le ministère de la défense
aujourd'hui annoncé l'ouverture d'un
certain nombre de couloirs de corridor
humanitaire pour permettre aux civils de
quitter les de quitter la ville sachant
que l'armée syrienne est à une dizaine
de kilomètres venant de la ville
donc oui je pense que ce qui ce qui a
aussi changé du côté loyaliste c7 va du
côté russe surtout parce que le pool le
pouvoir servir à d'autres préoccupations
c'est d'éviter
d'éviter les catastrophes humanitaires
trop visible trop ostentatoire comme à
l'époque d'aller uniquement pour l'image
où il ya des vrais résultats quand même
sur le terrain il ya beaucoup de choses
à la fois il ya d'un côté l'image
évidemment parce que la réputation de la
réussite en jeu sur la scène
internationale il ya aussi la volonté de
rassurer les éventuels partenaires
arabes susceptibles de revenir et de
participer à la reconstruction du pays
la russie compte sur des sur les pays de
la région pour l'aider à reconstruire le
pays compte aussi sur des puissances
plus grands tels je pense à l'inde à la
chaîne donc il y à cet aspect il y à
aussi la relation qui est pour moi une
la relation capitale la relation central
de cette de cette ultime étape du
conflit c'est la relation entre la
russie et la turquie
alors évidemment on exagère toujours
dans les deux sens soit on exagère la
lie la proximité entre turcs et russes
en parlant à tort d'alliance soit on
exagère en parlant à tort de rupture dès
qu'il ya un accrochage entre l'armée
syrienne et la nature je pense que en ce
moment il y à des transactions entre la
russie et la turquie et ses transactions
concernent à la fois le nord-ouest et le
nord-est
c'est à dire la fameuse zone de sécurité
obtenu par la turquie qui pourrait se
transformer demain
merci beaucoup à l'ena mohammedi nous
avons apporté votre éclairage
l'union européenne est parvenue à un
accord pour déployer des navires de
guerre à l'est de la libye afin
d'empêcher les livraisons d'armes dans
le pays un accord qui porte uniquement
sur la livraison d'armes et non pas sur
la question des migrants les
explications de florian lambert un
accord commun pour lancer une nouvelle
mission navale en libye
l'union européenne est parvenue ce lundi
un accord pour déployer des navires de
guerre à l'est de la libye un accord
inattendu dans se félicite le chef de la
diplomatie européenne
josette borel année nous avons convenu
de lancer une nouvelle opération en
méditerranée et l'opération sofia sera
fermée l'opération sofia toucher à sa
fin le 20 mars c'est ce jour-là
l'opération sofia se terminera mais nous
allons lancer une nouvelle opération en
méditerranée et nous avons convenu que
cette opération aura pour objectif la
mise en oeuvre de l'embargo sur les
armes imposé par le conseil de sécurité
des nations unies
une opération initiée en 2015 et qui a
pour but de contrôler les flux
migratoires et les causes des trafics
humains en méditerranée autre volet de
l'opération sofia l'entraînement des
garde côtes libyens depuis l'été 2010 8
ils sont chargés par l'europe de
coordonner les sauvetages de réfugiés
une mission que la libye en guerre était
incapable de mener à bien
selon les ong
le commandant veux préciser qu'il y a eu
90 morts lorsque nous étions au large
près de la côte de garat bulli à l'est
de tripoli en libye
et qu'il n'y avait pas de bateau pour
les sauver parmi les réticents l'italie
ou encore l'autriche qui voyaient dans
l'opération sofia un billet d'entrée en
europe pour des milliers de migrants
clandestins des navires de guerre seront
envoyés fin mars dans les eaux à l'est
de la libye si ces livraisons de
permettre le transport illégal de
migrants l'accord entre les états
membres sera rompu oui pour en parler
nous sommes avec à claude blanchemaison
expert en relations internationales
bonsoir claude blanchemaison merci
d'être avec nous en direct sur rt from
ans l'union européenne qui va donc
lancer une nouvelle mission navale pour
contrôler l'embargo des armes
qu'est ce que ça signifie concrètement
j'ai un petit peu moins d'un mois après
la conférence de berlin où une douzaine
de pays s'étaient réunis pour examiner
la situation en libye et voir ce qui
pouvait être fait et effectivement tous
ces pays avaient constaté qu' il y avait
du trafic d'armes
eva remarque continuer à arriver en
libye malgré les résolutions l'embargo
de l'onu et les états participants
avaient promis de faire ce qu'il pouvait
pour empêcher ce trafic d'armes et bien
l'union européenne fait aujourd'hui ce
qui pouvait être fait et c'est un petit
peu un miracle parce que les pays de
l'union européenne était très divisée
c'est probablement un succès personnel
pour josette borel
le représentant de l'union européenne
pour la politique extérieure et de
sécurité puisqu'il a habilement négocié
pour aboutir à un consensus
alors on a vu que c'était un début
difficile du côté italien du côté
autrichien puisque les indiens avaient
très peur d'une augmentation des
réfugiés puisque si on crée une nouvelle
force militaire c'est-à-dire que des
navires militaires mis à disposition par
les états membres de l'union européenne
volontairement vont patrouiller dans la
partie est de la de la côte de la côte
de la libye et avec pour but d'empêcher
d'intercepter les trafics d'armes
évidemment si
il y à des réfugiés sur un esquif en
danger est la loi internationale oblige
en principe à leur porter secours
et c'est ce que voulait éviter les
italiens donc les italiens ont deux
clauses de sauvegarde qui est une
si ça se produisait si on les a mis dans
les ports italiens et bien là le la
sphère s'arrêterait là
c'est à dire que la la force
n'existerait plus et puis comme moyen
terme les italiens dit si c'est un
bateau allemand qui prend les réfugiés
et bien il ya les amener en allemagne et
pas dans le port le plus proche
c'est à dire systématiquement un port
italien ou maltais donc c'est un bon
compromis qui est un début d'exécution
des décisions de berlin et les ministres
affaires étrangères on avait parlé hier
à munich en marge de la conférence sur
la sécurité qui se d âme unique comme
chaque année et probablement qu'il avait
évoqué cette hypothèse mais évidemment
c'est surtout un succès politique
ce consensus au sein de l'union
européenne est ce que ce sera efficace
ça reste à voir parce que le contrôle ne
sera que maritime
bien entendu avec les réserves de
l'italie que je viens de dire
on peut aussi acheminer des armes par la
voix des verts ou par la voie terrestre
et on sait que l'egypte soutient le
maréchal haftar que d'autres pays
voisins soutiennent plutôt le
gouvernement reconnu par l'onu de
tripoli alors la question comment claude
blanchemaison faire respecter l'embargo
c'est très compliqué parce que les
trafics d'armes peuvent être aussi
privée comme d'ailleurs les han guan
mercenaires pour soutenir une partie où
l'autre et on dit que actuellement
effectivement la turquie a envoyé
et troupes mais en réalité ce sont des
syriens des syriens qui est pro turc qui
ont probablement été envoyées on dit
aussi que la russie aurait envoyé des
gens du coup du côté d' avatar
le gouvernement russe a démenti en
disant non non il n'y a aucune troupe
russe et c'est probablement vrai si il y
à des combattants du côté des stars qui
viennent de russie se sont simplement
des mercenaires qui appartiennent à une
société privée
alors le pétrole libyen est quasiment à
l'arrêt en cyrénaïque et dans le sud
quels sont les enjeux et pour tous alors
mais le jeu le maréchal haftar en effet
a mis à l'arrêt les puits de pétrole
c'est très important évidemment le
pétrole pour l'économie libyenne
puisque ça représente à peu près 95 %
des ressources budgétaires et ça
représente à peu près les deux tiers du
pib de libye donc et bien l'économie
libyenne et le budget des biens sont
amputé d'autant le maréchal haftar
pensait probablement lorsqu'il a pris
cette décision en janvier début janvier
que c'était un bon moyen de levier pour
faire réagir les grands pays
et notamment certains un pays qui ont
des intérêts directs en libye
évidemment il n'a pas eu beaucoup de
chance parce que le cours du pétrole en
ce moment en baisse et depuis le début
janvier il a baissé de 10% par
conséquent pour les grands pays
pétroliers c'est une véritable
bénédiction qui veut ça veut dire qu' il
n'y a plus de pétrole libyen qui
arrivent sur le marché pour peser à la
baisse
donc personne dans le fond on est très
tristes sauf peut-être évidemment le
gouvernement de tripoli
et puis les compagnies pétrolières qui
ne peuvent plus opérer alors le chef du
gouvernement justement libyen d'union
nationale reconnue au précisons le
rappel par l'onu fayez hajj déplore ne
pas avoir de partenaire de paix c'est ce
qu'il a dit hun sen vie pour trouver une
issue aux halles au confit de ce pays
est ce que vous êtes d'accord avec son
analyse et son regret pour le maréchal
haftar n'a pas envie de signer quoi que
ce soit puisque la fragile trêve qui
existe il n'a jamais voulu la
transformer en cessez le feu
il n'a jamais fourni accepté de signer
les documents même sous la pression
russe par conséquent le maréchal haftar
veut en découdre
il a l'intention de régler le problème
par des moyens militaires
cela dit le cessez le feu il existe avec
150 infraction à ce cessez le feu depuis
qu'il a été mis en place ce qui est
évidemment beaucoup donc je pense que le
vrai problème c'est l'absence d'un
véritable état en syrie et c'est bien le
problème qui a fait que que kadhafi a
également disparu puisque l'ours est un
peu la clé de voûte entre différentes
factions différentes tribus et
qu'aujourd'hui bas il ya toujours pas
déteint véritablement constituée mais
pour la pour l'union européenne c'est
évidemment une bombe à proximité de
l'union européenne notamment par la
menace de migrants merci beaucoup claude
blanche maison pour votre éclairage
expert en relations internationales
sergueï lavrov plaide pour la
coopération le ministre russe des
affaires étrangères s'est exprimé ce
matin face à la presse au lendemain de
la clôture à munich et de la conférence
sur la sécurité rendez vous annuel de la
diplomatie et de la défense sergueï
lavrov qui est revenu sur les
discussions de ces trois derniers jours
les participants se sont penchés sur la
question de la perte d'influencé progrès
de l'occident face au reste du monde
mise de la diplomatie russe met en avant
la volonté de son pays de travailler
avec la france et avec l'union
européenne
les précisions depuis munich de notre
envoyé spécial ben shemie au lendemain
de la 56e édition de la conférence de
munich sur la sécurité sergueï lavrov le
ministre des affaires étrangères russe
en a profité pour donner une conférence
de presse et revenir sur les travaux de
ces trois jours avec ses partenaires
européens ses partenaires internationaux
il a eu un mot pour emmanuel macron
parlant d'un président le pragmatique
ouvert au dialogue avec manuel macron
avait déclaré que la russie était un
partenaire avec lequel il fallait
travailler il ne fallait pas isolée elle
la russie est ça qu elle abreuve est
ouvert au dialogue avec paris je vous
propose d'écouter le ministre des
affaires étrangères russe en réalité de
la part de la france il ya eu des
propositions ou la france je dirais que
la france a manifesté une certaine
perspicacité en matière politique et un
certain pragmatisme et semble disposé à
un dialogue cela a été énoncé malgré
toutes les réserves qui a pu faire le
précédent macron à l'égard de la russie
mais il a appelé à prendre en
considération la situation réelle ce et
cela peut influencer un serveur de
processus qui sont cure qui sont en
cours donc nous nous sommes prêts à
travailler avec eux le nom européenne
sur fond d'un ensemble de déclarations
de la part des européens des américains
cela fait un peu dichotomie sergueï
lavrov est également revenu sur les
relations entre ankara et moscou en
disant que les deux armées travailler
conjointement à idlib notamment et
concernant est libre qu'une session de
discussions ont été ouvertes pour
trouver une voix une sortie de crise à
ce conflit est sortie de crise et cette
région dont la situation s'aggrave à
jour après jour il a également eu un mot
concernant l'otan en disant que le temps
avait cessé toute forme de relations
avec la russie et que la réussite est
ouverte aux discussions avec l'otan mais
l'otan doit arrêter d'aggraver la
situation sergueï lavrov est également
revenu sur le format normandie une
question a été posée sur le format
normande il a déclaré que moscou a vu
aucun progrès dans la mise en oeuvre des
décisions du sommet et normandie ralenti
parquet l'eac avant d'organiser un
nouveau format normandie les décisions
les conclusions de l'ancien format
devait être appliquée voilà les mots
qu'il a eus concernant cette
problématique il est revenu bien sûr sur
les différentes problématiques liées à
la région le conflit en syrie le conflit
en libye la course l'allemand les
relations avec l'iran et a déclaré que
moscou était prête à travailler
davantage avec la communauté
internationale la communauté européenne
sur l'agenda international et coup
d'envoi à moscou du forum annuel du club
valdaï pendant deux jours plus de 50
facteurs internationaux vont débattre de
la russie et de son rôle dans le monde
pour cette 17e édition le thème centrale
et le moyen-orient notre envoyé spécial
antoine cléroux et sur place c'est une
nouvelle édition du club valdaï qui
s'est tenue à moscou avec le thème
suivant le moyen-orient à l'ère du
changement vers une nouvelle
architecture de stabilité durant
plusieurs ateliers conférences une
cinquantaine d'intervenants de 20
nationalités différentes des enseignants
des chercheurs des universitaires ou
encore des responsables politiques ont
tour à tour pris la parole débattu sur
des problématiques liées au moyen-orient
et en marge du programme officiel
les discussions continuent on entend
tout autour de moi parler l'anglais
l'arabe le russe il faut dire que
l'actualité concernant cette partie du
monde et particulièrement chargé on peut
penser à au plan de paix américain
concernant le compte
israël aux palestiniens la situation en
libye l'avenir de l'accord sur le
nucléaire iranien ou encore l' escalade
militaire en syrie
entre les armées turque et syrienne du
justement à ce sujet j'ai pu recueillir
l'avis d'une spécialiste des questions
méditerranéennes et turcs je vous
propose d'écouter la russie à la turquie
était au départ il faut pas l'oublier
des des puissances qui avaient des
positions totalement différente sur la
crise syrienne elles ont été opposés
pendant très longtemps au point d'en
arriver à une véritable brouille
après qu'un avion russe ait été abattu
par des militaires turcs la
réconciliation elle s'est fait à un
moment où la turquie est en train de
tourner le dos de plus en plus à ses
alliés européens et américains donc
finalement c'est une réconciliation qui
s'est fait un peu par défaut du point de
vue des turcs mais de toute façon les
russes jusqu'à présent était absolument
dominant non ce rapport géopolitique
régionale et en particulier en syrie ce
qui s'est passé depuis trois ans et que
la turquie a mené à bien des opérations
militaires en syrie qui l'ont installé
dans le paysage sait rien et qui en ont
fait un protagoniste à part entière dont
les intérêts ne coïncident pas toujours
avec ceux des russes jusqu'à présent la
russie a réussi je dirais à contrôler
les dommages que ces interventions turcs
ont provoqué en syrie notamment ceux
faisant plus ou moins médiateur entre
les turcs et les kurdes
mais aujourd'hui est libre on arrive à
un moment de vérité pratiquement dans la
relation dessous turc
l'objectif de ce cycle de conférences
est donc de débattre de ces grands
sujets d'actualité mais aussi de
promouvoir une résolution pacifique des
conflits dans une partie du monde qui
cristallise temps de tension dans
quelques instants rester avec nous nous
parlerons de la réforme des retraites le
texte de loi est arrivé dans l'hémicycle
officiellement les passes d'armes ont
commencé sans compter les quarante et un
mille amendements déposés puis nous
reviendrons sur le coran navires us
au ministre de la santé olivier veyrat
assure que la gestion de la crise reste
sa priorité numéro un
[Musique]
c'est chacun pour soi dieu pour tous tes
pieds coût politique a jamais été obligé
de dire la vérité mais idée courageuse
des mots qui comptent
j'ai eu françois vient de l'ignorance
aujourd'hui on a une gauche qui extrait
tous les témoins de notre époque sont
dans la grande interview
est-ce qu'on a fini maman on a fini
maman non je suis sûr qu'on doit mettre
un terme à cette croissance
et je n'ai jamais vraiment été séduit
par l'idée de mettre des enfants au
monde parce que je sentais que le monde
n'allait pas bien et que la vie serait
synonyme pour eux de souffrance
[Musique]
cela nous ramène à cette idée qu'il n'y
a aucune raison de mettre plus d'enfants
au monde
vous prenez des êtres qui ont besoin
d'amour et voulait leur donner cet amour
personne ne veut en parler car tout le
monde a peur mais la survie de notre
espèce dépend vraiment de notre capacité
à résoudre ce problème
si nous ne pouvons même pas en parler on
va avoir de gros problèmes
cette histoire est étroitement liée à la
culture
c'est l'histoire d'une communauté
nollywood est un groupe de personnes qui
veulent vraiment raconter leur histoire
c'est comme sortir avec un homme marié
oui c'est comme de sortir avec un homme
marié tu dois le faire vite et pas cher
si tu fais vite
cela signifie que ce n'est pas cher
[Musique]
si tu veux faire des affaires ok et
coupez coupez
et battre al aqsa petit bordel tu as
rien à faire ici avec ton chariot
[Musique]
c'est votre avis
le prévenu
[Musique]
que veut-il dire en japonais et qui
comme henry lors il veut dire qui ne
sort pas de chez soi tout simplement le
propre du phénomène hikikomori c'est que
on trouve des jeunes au japon qui refuse
de sortir de chez eux alors qu'eux ils
n'ont pas de pathologie identifiée dans
la nomenclature psychiatriques
aujourd'hui les geeks maury ne sont pas
des fadas de jeux vidéo c'est pas des
gens qui passent tout leur temps dans
leur chambre scotché à l'ordinateur à
jouer aux jeux vidéo et c'est un
documentaire qui permet de comprendre
emploi ce phénomène est vraiment
spécifique de la culture japonaise au
japon la pression scolaire est
extrêmement forte
mais les parents s'endettent souvent à
vie pour que leurs enfants fassent des
études et puis vous savez au moment de
la crise d'adolescence un bel quelque
chose qui est remis en question
c'est une super méga crise d'adolescence
considérablement majorait par la
situation économique culturel social
familial qui lie au japon
[Musique]
bonsoir merci de nous rejoindre pour
cette deuxième heure d'émission tout de
suite voici les titres de l'actualité de
ce lundi le nouveau ministre de la santé
olivier vers en a donné cet après midi
le coup d'envoi devant les députés des
débats sur la réforme des retraites
vantant une ambition immense un texte
dénoncé par les oppositions qui
critiquent également le départ d'agnès
busin qui avait notamment à la charge de
ce dossier
le nombre de contaminations coronavirus
s'élève à au moins 70 1500 cas en chine
et environ 800 cas signalés dans une
trentaine d'autres pays les autorités
chinoises demande aux personnes guéries
de donner leur sang afin d'en extraire
le plasma pour soigner les malades des
vidéos avec des policiers diffusées sur
les réseaux sociaux elles sont de plus
en plus nombreux c'est à la demande de
certains syndicats que le ministère
conduit une étude juridique pour
restreindre les modalités de leur
diffusion cela poserait des problèmes de
sécurité pour les forces de l'ordre
alors faut-il rendre anonymes les
visages de ces policiers lors de la
diffusion vidéo ou ses vidéos sont elles
au contraire un garde-fou contre
d'éventuelles bavures ce sera l'objet de
notre face à face à 21h30
[Musique]
après dix jours en commission spéciale
les députés ont officiellement commencé
à débattre de la réforme des retraites à
l'assemblée nationale dans une ambiance
électrique
on retrouve tout de suite notre envoyé
spécial guillemin rossi bonsoir
guillemin vous êtes donc au coeur du
palais bourbon et le nouveau ministre de
la santé a lancé les débats
officiellement c'était il y à quelques
heures maintenant
oui tout à fait il y à quelques heures
son intervention a d'ailleurs fait
beaucoup réagir l'opposition notamment
la référence à ambroise croizat l'un des
pères de la sécurité sociale le
président de la chambre a d'ailleurs été
obligé de rappeler à l'ordre cette
opposition quelques minutes seulement
après le début du discours du nouveau
ministre de la santé
regarder devant vous et continuez
monsieur le ministre a encouragé richard
ferrand alors que l'expression du
mécontentement du côté de la france
insoumise couvrait à la voie du
successeurs d'agnès buzyn je vous
propose d'ailleurs d'écouter un extrait
du discours du nouveau ministre de la
santé olivier vers ont écouté le système
actuel à bien des qualités nous ne
manquons jamais de le rappeler est la
première d'entre elles est celle d'un
système qui fonctionne par répartition
mais il a aussi des défauts et ce sont
ses défauts que nous devons corriger le
premier c'est d'être d'une telle
complexité qu'il en devient
incompréhensible et qui ne suscite pas
la confiance notamment pour les plus
jeunes
je parle bien du système actuel mesdames
et messieurs les députés du haut de mes
trente neuf ans j'ai déjà cotisé à
quatre régimes de retraite différent
s'il vous plaît mais chacun sait aussi
que le système actuel est injuste pour
beaucoup de concitoyens
je pense aux femmes et à tous ceux
nombreux pour qui la vie professionnelle
n'a jamais été un long fleuve tranquille
l'ambition que porte le gouvernement est
triple construire un système universel
qui assure chaque français et où tout le
monde doit être assurée quel que soit
son parcours et quelle que soit sa
position prendre en compte les
trajectoires de vie en déplaçant notre
regard du statut vers l'activité et
enfin ce système doit mobiliser de
nouveaux leviers comme la prévention ou
le droit à la reconversion pour les
métiers les plus pénibles parce que oui
il faut le dire le système actuel laisse
au bord du chemin les plus fragiles de
nos concitoyens les moins représentées
il attend souvent trop longtemps pour
réparer au lieu de prévenir alors suite
à cette intervention et à celle d'autres
membres du gouvernement il y a eu l'
examen par les députés de deux motion de
rejet préalable
l'une contre le projet de loi ordinaire
déposée par le parti communiste et
l'autre contre le projet de loi
organique cette fois-ci déposés par les
républicains alors qu'est-ce que un
projet qu'est ce que pardon une motion
de rejet préalable et ben c'est une
procédure qui permet de faire
reconnaître que l'une ou plusieurs des
dispositions d'un texte est
anticonstitutionnelle et donc d'annuler
les débats d'annuler l'examen du texte
il y a eu ensuite l'examen d'une motion
référendaire alors une motion
référendaire lorsqu'elle est signée par
au moins 10% des députés et qu'elle est
adoptée par l'ensemble de à l'assemblée
nationale permet de demander au
président de la république d'organiser
un référendum sur le sujet débattu
alors bien entendu comme vous pouvez
l'imaginer aucune de ces mentions n'a
été adoptée en réalité l'issue du vote
ne faisait pas beaucoup de doute
tours mais en réalité tout ceci faisait
partie d'une stratégie d'abord gagner du
temps bien entendu et ensuite se faire
entendre
et puis il ya une autre stratégie c'est
celle de l'obstruction comme vous le
savez plus de 40 mille amendements ont
été déposés quarante mille deux cent
soixante dix sept amendements très
exactement le vote final quant à lui
doit avoir lieu le 3 mars prochain mais
vu les délais vu la charge de travail il
ya peu de chances que les délais que
quinze jours soit suffisant pour
examiner tous ses amendements et pour
examiner le texte dans son ensemble
donc encore une fois un quarante mille
amendements c'est à dire près de 2700
amendements à examiner par jour on est
donc bien en face d'une obstruction
parlementaire ici à l'assemblée
nationale et comme l'a dit richard
ferrand les députés vont avoir des
heures des jours et des nuits pour
examiner ce texte
merci à guillaume un aussi en direct
donc de l'assemblée nationale et je vous
repose justement d'écouter ces réactions
recueillies dans les couloirs n'est pas
les bonbons ces amendements étaient
déclinés sur les 16 députés de notre
groupe
mais la totalité de ces amendements on
peut aussi à 800 amendements que l'on a
décliné effectivement sont des
amendements de fond qui détricote le
projet de loi qui décortique projet de
loi et qui montre à quel point il est
régressif et du droit des conséquences
terribles terrible pour le votre est top
à partir du moment où on hystérise on
théâtralise le débat par des amendements
qui n'ont aucun sens qu'ils sont des
amendements prétexte dont le seul but
est d'allonger et d'embourber le débat
je pense que le principal risque c'est
que cette débat de clarté ce débat
démocratique soit confisquée
je trouve ça dommage cette réforme va
faire baisser de futurs pensionnés les
jeunes
d'au moins entre 10 et 20% leur pension
de retraite c'est considérable et quel
est le moyen que nous avons si ce n'est
d'alerter l'opinion est alerté les
parlementaires sur leur responsabilité
pleine journée symbolique pour les
opposants à ce projet de loi ils se sont
mobilisés une fois le plus dans la
capitale direction précisément
l'assemblée nationale un dispositif
important de forces de l'ordre avaient
été déployés parmi eux eric coquerel de
la france en soumises ou encore olivier
besancenot du npa n'est conscient que
c'est pas l'intérêt du parlement que les
choses vont se passer mais à l'extérieur
et c'est pour ça qu'on est venu
simplement d'abord se rappeler au bon
souvenir de l'assemblée nationale de
leur député pour dire qu on les oubliera
pas et n'oubliera pas qu'ils comptent
voter quoi et dire à travers eux que à
emmanuel macron que nous va pas lâcher
la faire avec le mouvement de rue
mouvement de grève demeure de
manifestations mobilisations
il doit continuer ce sera la seule issue
pour gagner pourtant on est condamné à
tous taper sur le même clou parce que si
vous ne tapez pas tous sur le même clou
on n'y arrivera jamais donc que ça soit
par une manifestation nationale la
généralisation de la grève on a besoin
de replanter dans le décor le fait qu'on
n'est pas des rigolos et qu' on n'a pas
fait tout ce qu'on a fait depuis le 5
décembre simplement pour gagner la
bataille des idées
aulas l'ambiance dans l'hémicycle c'est
sur la même chose hier on a des des
ministres qui nous font du discours à la
orwell en permanence d'accord qui nous
explique ce serait une loi de protection
sociale de justice sociale certains ont
même acquis au même parler de démocratie
sociale c'est ça qui est le plus
insupportable ils sont en train de
démanteler un des piliers du patrimoine
social français et ils font mine de
quelque part vouloir en réalité du
progrès alors qu'ils ne font que reculer
l'âge de la retraite par la presse
attaquer les pensions sans aucune
légitimité donc je peux vous dire je
pense que dans l'assemblée ça va ça va
être assez chaud pendant plusieurs
semaines et pour en parler mons à nous
avec axel perdre son secrétaire général
cgt cheminots de trazbon square accède
person merci d'être avec nous vous avez
manifesté aujourd'hui plusieurs de mes
camarades était mannequin manifestation
aujourd'hui à titre personnel j'ai pas
pu y aller mais oui avec plusieurs de
mes camarades qui étaient en
manifestation aujourd'hui devant
l'assemblée nationale oui alors à la
mobilisation attendue après on savait
que ça n'allait pas être la même ampleur
que les manifestations précédentes
n'avait pas tapé par les mêmes
organisations par qui n'ont pas
forcément la même force de frappe mais
il y avait quand même quelques milliers
de personnes de tous tous les avis
qu'ils ont commenté la participation qui
témoigne du fait que même si le projet
aujourd'hui discutée à l'assemblée
nationale l'opposition elle continue à
s'exprimer avec ceux prescrits mais à
nouveau d'ailleurs dans des proportions
sans doute un peu plus importante à
nouveau jeudi qui arrive le jeudi 20 où
nous serons nombreux à être à nouveau en
grève et aux manifestations à nouveau
quoi est justement vous croyez que ça va
peser puisque ce fait des semaines des
mois qu'il ya des mobilisations et a eu
de grandes grèves qui ont bloqué la
france qui pour l'instant n'ont pas eu
l'effet escompté
du point de vue des opposants à ce que
désormais vous n'estimez pas que la
bataille se fait au parlement une partie
de certains en tout cas parlementaire
mène la bataille politique dans le
parlement en effet mais après il
faudrait quand même aussi est nuancée
justement ce constat parce que quand on
constate le point de départ du projet
gouvernemental et patronales
il ya eu des inflexions insuffisante au
demeurant qui ont été accordés au fur et
à mesure que la grève s'est étendue et
des concessions quant à accorder à
différentes professions mobilisé y
compris les nôtres donc ça au contraire
ça conforte l'idée que c'est par la
grève qu'on avait à défendre ses
intérêts en revanche en effet dans la
mesure où le texte n'a pas été retirée
oui l'objectif qu'on s'est fixé au
départ n'a pas encore été atteint
partant de ce constat nous ce qu'on dit
c'est qu'il faut continuer la
mobilisation est en effet on pense pas
que c'est au parlement que ça va se
jouer
c'est même si c'est une étape parmi nos
dans la bataille mais que c'est bien
dans les grèves et les manifestations
qu'on pourra obtenir satisfaction de
l'objectif à savoir le retrait du projet
de loi vous le dites vous même vous avez
obtenu des concessions vous les
cheminots c'est le cas également
d'autres pros de profession est ce que
vous y croyez vraiment à ce retrait
total la part du gouvernement
en fait j'y crois dans la mesure
uniquement j'ai dû bien uniquement ça
dépend des travailleurs si les
travailleurs se mobilisent massivement
oui en effet ils n'auront pas le choix
que de le retirer
mais si la mobilisation est insuffisante
bas on ne pourra pas dépasser le constat
qu'on a fait tout à l'heure c'est à dire
des inflexions à certaines catégories et
en plus les inflexions ne sont pas de
nature non plus à calmer la colère y
compris auprès des cheminots parce que
les concessions qui était accordé son
catégorielles elles sont générationnel
elles concernent souvent des agents ou
des salariés qui sont en poste mais
souvent prive les générations à venir
des mêmes droits
donc même si le gouvernement recule en
partie sur son projet même ça ce n'est
pas suffisant mais en effet il y en a
pas que d'autres choix que de poursuivre
par la grève et il va falloir trouver
des moyens de l'amplifier est de la
maintenir dans la durée
il va y revenir sur ses moyens il
n'empêche on a dit un le débat a été
lancé officiellement l'assemblée
nationale avec ce nouveau ministre qu'on
a vu sur ces images olivier verront vous
avez trouvé comment ce ministre c'est un
peu trop tôt pour
après on essaie c'est quelqu'un qui
s'est déjà illustré par le passé parce
qu'il n'est pas de tout à fait anonyme
il s'était notamment illustrée par la
volonté notamment je sais pas si les
auditeurs s'en souviennent mais de
s'attaquer notamment référence à la
sécurité sociale
plusieurs fois dans les années qui se
sont écoulées donc il s'inscrit dans la
ligne politique qui est celle du
gouvernement donc partant de là il
n'aura pas beaucoup de différence avec
sa prédécesseure is ses prédécesseurs sa
prédécesseur au ministère et va
poursuivre la même politique donc la
question ce n'est pas tant la personne
en réalité c'est plutôt la politique et
humaine dont on sait qu'elle sera pas si
différente que ça de ads buzyn ça a pas
l'air de vous choquer justement ce
changement de ministres sur des très
gros dossier amis de la santé les
retraites évidemment mais aussi le
corona virus la réforme de l'hôpital les
urgences on change de ministre pour
aller courir les municipales qu'est ce
que ça vous inspire vous oui évidemment
pour
pour le personnel hospitalier
dans la mesure où ils sont dans un
secteur qui subit d'une part la crise
sanitaire là qu'ils doivent gérer mais
en plus de ça une obligation
préexistantes qui dure depuis plusieurs
mois qu'il n'a pas trouvé d'issue
favorable en effet le message qui est
envoyé 2
de changer à la tête du ministère pour
aller en effet satisfaire aux exigences
électorales du gouvernement à paris
suite à la crise qui a eu avec benjamin
griveaux peut envoyer le signal comme
quoi les priorités du gouvernement ne
sont pas forcément celles du personnel
mobilisé mais ce que je tenais aussi à
souligner c'est que peu importe en fait
ceux qui sont au gouvernement
ce qui compte ce n'est pas tant les
personne c'est la politique qui est
menée ils sont tous d'accord sur
l'objectif qui est savoir de détruire
l'hôpital public donc que ce soit lui ou
un autre vous justement c'est une
illustration que quoi qu'il arrive les
décisions sont prises le fait que les
ministres changent elles et les projets
restent oui bien sûr bien sûr que ça
cesse date pas de ce gouvernement là
mais oui en effet la
l'interchangeabilité des personnes qui
dira les différents ministères témoins
avant tout de la continuité de la
politique est menée mais on a eu le même
chose sur le dossier des retraites
puisqu'il y avait un haut-commissaire
chez tous et un secrétaire d'état jean
pierre delevoye qui a qui suit pendant
la grève d'ailleurs même si c'était pas
forcément liée à la grève mais a dû
démissionner ils ont remplacé
ce monsieur par laurent empiétera ses
skis qui mènent la même politique en
réalité donc ce personnel politique là
et interchangeables et mènera la même
politique donc l'interlocuteur importe
peu en réalité alors néanmoins le
gouvernement affirme de son côté qu'il
continue à négocier d'ailleurs la
conférence de financement débute demain
est ce que c'est une chance pour vous
que les syndicats trouvent tout de même
un compromis tout ça dépend l'objectif
pour nous en tout cas n'est pas de
trouver un compromis et puisqu'on être
parce qu'on nous on est on est attaqué
donc le constat qu'on fait c'est quand
on attaque il faut se défendre on
cherche pas vraiment à chercher de
compromis par la discussion
d'autant plus que les dés sont pipés
puisque le gouvernement l'a dit lui même
il a fixé le cap de cette soi-disant de
conférence où elle dit que si un accord
qui n'est pas trouvée sachant que il a
exclu d'emblée tout ce qu'il appelle la
hausse du coût du travail c'est à dire
pas d'augmentation des salaires pas
d'augmentation des cotisations
susceptible de financer les caisses de
retraite
partant de là le seul levier sur lequel
il veut jouer ben c'est l'âge de départ
à la retraite
donc s'il n'y a pas d'accord qui est
trouvé il a dit lui-même il réintroduire
aller les mesures qui avaient été
rejetés à savoir l'âge déquilibre fixe à
60 80 qui se décalera au fur et à mesure
du temps aujourd'hui clairement et axel
person comment on en sort le 49-3 la
motion de censure les amendements on
voit que certains dénoncent plutôt une
obstruction aux débats parlementaires
les grèves dans la rue qui ont encore
une fois n'ont pas donné grand chose
jusqu'à présent est ce qu'on va en
sortir selon vous
vous risquez une déception avec la
poursuite de ce projet non après ces
mêmes questions de déception pas ou ne
peuvent pas sur le terrain moral on est
engagé dans une bataille
donc on utile on a trop on décide
quelles sont les armes qu'on utilise
pour ce pur pour se défendre
et là on sur laquelle déçu ça voudrait
qu'on avait des illusions sur le
gouvernement on sait que ce gouvernement
est déterminé à détruire à peu près tous
les droits sociaux qui existent dans ce
pays
donc ce n'est pas une déception dans la
mesure n'avait pas d'illusions oui ça
pourrait être un échec mais ceci étant
dit ce qu'on peut constater depuis que
le gouvernement à ce gouvernement là aux
manettes c'est qu' il n'y a pas une
seule journée bon j'exagère un peu mais
pas ceux ayant un seul trimestre un seul
mois dans lequel il n'y a pas eu des
mobilisations qui s'exprime et de plus
en plus forte parce qu'il ya eu
évidemment ce mouvement qui est en cours
sur la bataille des retraites mais il
était précédé par celui des gilet jaune
qui a lui-même été précédé par celui qui
avait mené déjà les cheminées en 2018 et
on voit qu contrat au fur et mesure que
le temps avance pas que les oppositions
se multiplient et ont tendance même à se
durcir donc on verra bien jusqu'où ça
ira mais on constate au contraire que ce
n'est pas la résignation qui domine mais
au contraire décodeur qui s'exprime de
plus en plus fort tout l'enjeu pour nous
en tant que militant c'est d'arriver à
structurer ses colères et leur donner
une vision d'ensemble et un programme
d'ensemble pour qu'ils puissent se
battre tous ensemble avec le même
objectif pour l'instant on n'y est pas
arrivé entièrement mais on amer nous on
a avancé en tout cas vers cet objectif
merci beaucoup a excellé à personne
d'avoir été avec nous en direct sur arte
france merci à vous et on en parlait
justement il venait d'être nommé
rapporteur du volet organique de la
réforme des retraites olivier verront
donc pris la casquette du
ministre de la santé la passation de
pouvoir s'est déroulée ce matin avec
agnès buzyn ce médecin neurologue
jusque-là député la république en marge
de l'isère occupée depuis deux ans et
demi le poste de rapporteur général de
la commission des affaires sociales
agnès buzyn a démissionné hier de ses
fonctions pour se lancer dans la
bataille des municipales parisiennes en
remplacement de benjamin griveaux on
écoute le des messieurs c'est avec une
grande émotion que je quitte de résister
l'originalité la cité mener la campagne
des élections municipales à paris j'ai
l'âme il hier soir ma démission au
premier ministre et au président la
république qui dézone liste vous
l'imaginez c'est un déchirement
pendant plus de deux ans et demi j'ai
l'honneur de conduire des politiques de
santé et les politiques de soutien de
notre pays
quel bilan agnès abusant les stèles au
ministère de la santé la réponse de
gérard grisey kirneck médecin urgentiste
on a été touché il ya deux ans quand
elle a pris deux ans et demi quand elle
a pris ministère de la santé on s'est
dit tiens médecin hospitalière qui
connaît bien ce côté sincérité comme ça
spontanée le problème c'est que depuis
deux ans et demi c'est une catastrophe
le bilan politique du ministère de la
santé depuis deux ans et demi ce sont
des hôpitaux qui sont grève des services
d'urgence qui sont en grève depuis 11
mois ce sont des plans comme ma santé
2022 qui ne répondent à aucune attente
ni de la population ni des médecins
généralistes
l'idée hospitalier mille démission de
chef de service ya à peine un mois bref
on voit bien que depuis deux ans et demi
la situation n'a fait que s'aggraver
dans le bilan politique est un mauvais
bilan politique on parle la crise du
coronavirus voilà il n'y a pas eu de
crise du corner virus parce qu'il n'ya
pas que coronavirus ont trié pas de
dangerosité
à date de ce virus sinon je pense qu'on
aura été très très mal pour pouvoir le
gérer
en tout cas nous on va pas le regretter
et on va pas regretter non plus la
surdité qu'on avait au ministère de la
santé tous les syndicats sont deux
d'accord commun pour dire il n'y avait
pas d' écoute n'y avait pas de dialogue
donc je sais pas comment ça va se passer
sur une campagne municipale mais en tout
cas il n'y avait pas de dialogue au
ministère qui quitte donc ses fonctions
pleine crise du coronavirus le nombre
quotidien de décès est en baisse pour la
troisième journée consécutive
l'organisation mondiale de la santé elle
aimait des réserves ont fait le point
avec leila sarah en dehors de la chine
continentale des malades dans une
trentaine de pays du monde
un ralentissement du nombre quotidien de
décès a notamment été notifié si ce
dernier bilan semble confirmer une
décrue l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a lancé un appel à la prudence
il est impossible de prévoir quelles
directions l'épidémie prendra nous
demandons à tous les gouvernements
toutes les sociétés et tous les
organismes de presse de travailler avec
nous pour déclencher le niveau d'alarmé
idoine sans souffler sur les braises de
l'hystérie l'épidémie maintient la
planète en alerte
un seul mot d'ordre aujourd'hui la
coopération la chine a un solide système
de santé publique
la chine a un solide système
scientifique et de découverte
la chine a la capacité de développer et
d'augmenter la production de vaccins
nous devons donc travailler avec la
chine des experts internationaux
dépêchés à pékin par l' oms ont commencé
à étudier l'épidémie du nouveau
coronavirus qu'ovide 19 avec leurs
homologues chinois
une collaboration dont le monde entier
espèrent qu'elle portera ses fruits
rapidement et pour en parler nous sommes
en direct depuis baltimore aux états
unis avec jennifer nuzzo
épidémiologistes chercheuse au son de
sécurité sanitaire de l'université johns
hopkins merci d'être avec nous c'est
notre rubrique vu de l'extérieur
[Musique]
et bonsoir docteur no merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france une petite
question qui peut peut-être nationale
mais je serai curieuse d'avoir votre
point de vue d' american en france donc
la ministre de la santé qui démissionne
pour se lancer dans une élection un
international la mairie de paris en
l'occurrence en plein coronavirus ça
vous inspire quoi vous ça pourrait
arriver et ça serait critiquée non aux
états unis un changement de direction
en période de crise ce n'est pas idéal
et j'espère qu'il y à des fonctionnaires
qui sont présents pour continuer ce
travail c'est vraiment essentiel c'est
là que se trouve l'expertisé technique
avoir une personnalité forte respecter
afin de diriger et d'être le visage
public de la réaction c'est très
important
justement c'est intéressant ce que vous
nous dites parce que qu'est ce qui vous
semble vous le plus important tant que
médecin chercheur
les pouvoirs publics ont un rôle
extrêmement important à jouer où il faut
plutôt compter sur les grands organismes
comme l'om est ce qu est ce qui est
finalement le plus important dans ce
type de crise les décisions prises par
les pouvoirs publics sont majeurs
j'étais nationale et son nationale sont
essentielles c'est elle qui vont assurer
le travail au niveau des communautés
le ms bien sûr est une ressource
importante mais il s'agit notamment d'un
organisme et ne sera pas tout coeur des
opérations notamment dans ce cas de
figure où il ya des problèmes c'est
traiter de monde entier et non pas la
version suffisance autorités de santé
nationales et locales seront donc en
première ligne
alors revenons en aux chiffres au moins
70 1500 cas en chine un peu plus de 1700
décès environ 800 autres cas signalés
dans d'autres pays
quel est votre regard de spécialiste de
médecins sur ces chiffres qu'il ya des
dizaines de milliers de cas rapportés
chaque jour c'est parce que je vois que
dans de nombreux pays les cas ne sont
pas liés à des voyages en chine et qu'on
trouve des cas au sein de la communauté
cela montre que la propagation du virus
est très rapide et très discrète donc il
est très difficile d'essayer de répondre
de réagir en renforçant les frontières
nationales en essayant d'éviter
l'importation du virus au dans les pays
aujourd'hui nous devons présumer que
tous les pays sont peuvent être
contaminés et nous devons donc mettre en
place des mesures afin d'atténuer
l'impact du virus est à dire essayer de
protéger les individus qui seraient les
plus susceptibles à des maladies telles
que les personnes âgées ou les personnes
qui ont des comorbidités il faut
s'assurer que les lits d'hôpitaux soient
réservés aux personnes qui en auront
vraiment besoin et qu'il ne s'agisse pas
simplement d'isoler des personnes qui
ont des cas bénins cas à ce jour était
assez bénin et
il faut donc on doit concentrer et
concentrer nos ressources limitées sur
les personnes qui à risque le plus suite
à ce virus justement on a beaucoup parlé
de ce paquebot vos ressortissants
américains les croisiéristes sont
finalement rentrés heureusement pour eux
de 14 cas positifs
ils sont d'ailleurs étaient placés en
quarantaine telle est votre réaction
c'était la bonne décision à prendre
j'ai exprimé mes critiques vis-à-vis de
cette approche je ne pense pas que cela
à permettra d'empêcher l'introduction dû
virus est là ce genre d'opération laisse
penser qu'on pourrait échapper au virus
mais c'est impossible et je pense que
cela détourne les ressources publiques
qui admet du travail important qui doit
être mise en oeuvre dans la communauté
pour elle me dit j'ai atténuer l'impact
du virus
ce sont les mêmes personnes qui essayent
de soutenir ces personnes encore en
chine devraient en quarantaine devraient
travailler avec les hôpitaux avec
communauté pour se préparer à la
propagation du virus
donc je suis assez inquiète que nous
concentrons nos ressources au mauvais
endroit vous dit elle devrait se
préparer
à lutter contre la propagation du virus
est ce qu'on doit y voir un signe
d'inquiétude delà de votre part vous
craignez justement une plus grande
propagation du virus les prochaines
semaines cela ressemble beaucoup à ce
que nous avons vu en 2009 avec la grippe
en 2009 une fois comme ça ont vu
l'apparition d'un nouveau virus de la
grippe
il s'est répandu dans tout le pays très
rapidement alors qu'on essaie justement
de le limiter de limiter son expansion
je pense que nous devrions anticipé elle
était qu' il y aura beaucoup de
propagation fait état de cas et donc ce
sont les pays en fait qui recherchent le
virer ce temps qu'il faut que nous
étendions notre surveillance se rendront
se trouve véritablement le virus et nous
concentrer sur les communautés afin de
réduire l'impact du virus et non pas
essayer simplement de l'empêcher de
rentrer dans les pays au niveau des
frontières nationales car nous savons
pas où est le virus en ce moment et dans
le monde
cela rend une approche et jeux
graphiques très difficile justement rien
des agences de tourisme qui pointe la
baisse de tourisme en asie chez ces
prochains temps est-ce que vous
approuvez ce qu' il est nécessaire
justement pour les touristes aujourd'hui
d'éviter la zone asiatique selon vous
[Musique]
pour lesquels le voyage est moins
populaire c'est effectivement ces
inquiétudes vis à vis du virus
il ya également beaucoup d'incertitudes
alors que s'agissant des réponses au
niveau national personne ne veut voyager
et se retrouve en quarantaine dans un
pays étranger donc la certitude qu'ils
habitent et réactions nationales ont
aussi un impact sur le tourisme
il faut étudier tous les toutes les
conséquences de ce virus au niveau de la
santé mais également
au niveau des gouvernements qui pourrait
prendre des mesures renforçant l'impact
économique de ce virus
nous ne voulons pas adopter des mesures
qui sont pierre pour les pays que le
virus lui-même donc nous devons tout est
examiné aujourd'hui certains
observateurs disent qu'on en fait
peut-être un peu trop bu et la grippe
finalement tu beaucoup plus de personnes
est ce que vous partagez tout de même
cette analyse est ce qu'il faut à ce
point s'inquiéter le virus pose problème
est inquiétant est la raison pour
laquelle cette inquiétude continue c'est
qu'il ya beaucoup d'inconnues dans la
situation notamment
c'est encore de découvrir de comprendre
la gravité de l'impact de ce virus
effectivement s'il s'agit simplement de
compter les décès c'est déjà assez
inquiétant et c'est plus important que
toute autre maladie récente mais je ne
pense pas que ces estimations sont
parfaitement exact je pense que tous les
cas qu'il est important de rassembler
plus d'informations pour nous en assurer
le niveau et d'attention et et
pertinents c'est une nouvelle situation
et il faut se méfier des possibilités
négative
il ya des informations qui peuvent être
optimiste mais je pense que les gens ne
devraient pas se penser que le niveau
d'attention reflète le risque rapidement
parce que nous arrivons malheureusement
la fin de cette interview le vaccin vous
l'espérez pour quand j'ai entendu
beaucoup d'estimations parle de
l'automne ou d'un an et plus est
malheureusement le vaccin prend toujours
plus de temps qu'on ne le soit 2009 nous
avions un vaccin existe et déjà qu'ils
étaient déjà en place
et pourtant cela a pris plus longtemps
que nous le souhaitions pour développer
un nouveau vaccin que j'espère que toute
cette attention concentrer sur le virus
et dramé je pense pas qu'il faut
s'attendre à un accès rapide
merci beaucoup de jennifer yuh d'avoir
été avec nous en direct sur rt france
reste avec nous dans quelques instants
notre débat sur la diffusion de vidéos
avec des policiers sur les réseaux
sociaux
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce que si c'est interdit d'interdire
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
soyez les bienvenus en direct sur rt
france merci de nous rejoindre un
c'était le 3 janvier dernier cédric show
via subissait une interpellation
violente qu'il avait filmés provoquant
ainsi la colère des forces de l'ordre
l'homme est décédé quelques minutes plus
tard à la demande d'un syndicat de
police
un contrôle pourrait être mis en place
pour la diffusion de vidéos les
explications en images
[Musique]
rang
il
m
[Musique]
des vidéos avec des policiers diffusées
sur les réseaux sociaux elles sont de
plus en plus nombreux c'est à la demande
des syndicats le ministère conduit donc
une étude juridique pour restreindre les
modalités de leur diffusion cela pose la
question de la sécurité des forces de
l'ordre faut-il rendre anonymes les
visages les policiers lors de la
diffusion de vidéos ou ses vidéos son
talent contraire un rempart contre
d'éventuelles bavures c'est l'objet de
notre face à face et pour en débattre ce
soir nous sommes avec mohamed keita
photographe de terrain bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous à ses côtés stanislas
godon secrétaire général adjoint du
syndicat alliance police bonsoir sur
stanislas godon merci d'être avec nous
en direct sur arte france vous êtes
justement l'un des syndicats très en
pointe sur cette demande de d'anonymiser
ne m'aurait pas facile à dire le visage
des policiers d'éviter de diffuser voilà
sur les réseaux sociaux ces vidéos de
violence dont christophe castaner qui
envisage de contrôler la diffusion de
ces vidéos vous êtes satisfait justement
qu'est une réponse du ministre même si
les choses ne sont pas encore fait
on va être très prudent parce que les
choses effectivement ne sont pas encore
faites elles sont pour l'instant au
stade de l'année juridique puisque le
texte est complexe à mettre en place
il fait partie notamment des
modifications de la loi de 80 donc c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile mais c'est
néanmoins nécessaire pour l'ensemble de
mes collègues parce que il faut pas
oublier que non seulement parfois on a
des spécialistes qui viennent filmer au
coeur notamment de l'événement ça
perturbe parfois l'intervention
policière et puis surtout le plus
important je crois c'est qu'il faut pas
oublier que les policiers
ben ils subissent souvent des attaques
parfois certains ont à leur domicile
notamment des lettres de menace pour eux
pour leurs familles donc je crois qu'il
est nécessaire quand même de les
protéger
ces policiers surtout que le fait de
montrer leur visage n'apporte absolument
rien puisque s'il devait y avoir une
enquête pour quoi que ce soit pour
quelques raisons que ce soit en fait il
y aurait des saisines notamment des
vidéos et elles seraient exploités de la
même manière que si elle n'avait pas été
floutés donc ce que vous voulez éviter
pour bien qu'on comprenne c'est la
diffusion sur internet du tout à chacun
qui pourrait voir ses vidéos mais en
tout cas évidemment pas empêché la
justice en tout cas légers peine de s'en
servir pour d'éventuelles enquêtes c'est
bien car ça c'est pas le sujet le sujet
c'est de protéger réponse est non mais
c'est pour ça que bon mediapart a fait
un article qui est un peu un peu
polémique notamment par rapport à son
titre mais bon on a l'habitude en tout
cas nous dans les propos qu'on a tenu
notamment dans lors de cette interview
ils sont extrêmement claires nous sommes
pour l'anonymisation des policiers par
rapport à leur exercice de fonction dans
le cadre régalien de l'état et notamment
lorsqu'ils sont sur la voie publique
voit tout simplement
stanislas go dont vous vous êtes
justement un trouble fête entre
guillemets c'est nice a des gens qui
filme au milieu des manifestations vous
faites partie des gens qui fument vous
êtes reporters de terrain vous avez
participé à de nombreuses manifestations
photo appareil photo à la main et
caméras
la main cette demande de la part des
policiers vous la trouvez tout même
légitime ou elle vous choque me choque
un peu parce que je pense qu'il n'y a
pas vraiment de risque en fait pour les
policiers c'est pas eux qui sont mises
en danger en fait dans les
manifestations au contraire en fait nous
c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles on
films pour lesquels moi moi au départ je
prenais des photos j'étais photographe
ou manifestations et au bout d'un moment
bas pour pour notre sécurité
aussi on s'est dit mais en fait il faut
qu'on montre ce qui se passe est une
vidéo est plus parlante en fait est bon
quand s'est mis à filmer parce que je ne
veux pas que cueillez d'impunité en fait
c'est ça le la raison pour laquelle en
film stanislas godeau qu'est ce que vous
répondez c'est intéressant parce
qu'effectivement vos points de vue sont
totalement opposés vous vous mettez en
avant la sécurité des policiers
mohamed les femmes parlent effectivement
de peut-être de bavures d'impunité et
c'est pour cela qu'il faudrait fils mais
qu'est ce qu'on voulait réécouter l'ap
unités n'existe pas dans nos rangs
d'abord parce que les policiers sont
durement sanctionné je rappelle quand
même juste quelques chiffres 2030
sanction disciplinaire à l'encontre des
policiers nous représentons plus de 50%
des sanctions disciplinaires de la
fonction publique alors que nous
représentons que 7% de la fonction
publique elle-même
donc il y a cinq organismes de contrôle
c'est difficile quand même de passer au
travers
et puis dernière chose à l'heure
actuelle les vidéos qui sont notamment
instrumentalisé qui condamne d'ailleurs
les policiers avant même qu'il y ait des
enquêtes souvent ne reflète pas la
réalité sont sortis de leur contexte
et puis plus grave et
jette je dirais la vindicte populaire à
la vindicte médiatique des réseaux
sociaux notamment les policiers leur
famille également il faut pas l'oublier
donc nous on reste sur cette position
sur le fait qu'il faut aussi protéger
les policiers et leurs familles parce
que lorsque vous voyez votre visage sur
tous les réseaux sur toutes les vidéos
et que vos enfants les voient également
et que le policier
parfois il est dans une légitimité de l'
usage de la force légitime parce que
souvent on confond c'est pas parce qu'un
policier fait usage de la force qu'il
est forcément dans le cadre d'une d'un
dysfonctionnement ou d'un d'un usage de
la force
hors cadre réglementaire il faut pas
oublier que il y à un contexte alors
nous on avait saisi notamment la
ministre de l'intérieur c'est très
intéressant parce que c'était juste
avant tout les manifestations des gilets
jaunes voyez donc je n'a pas de rapport
avec notamment le contexte que l'on
connaît depuis 66 samedi notamment
et justement c'est intéressant mais de
gaffes ont dit ces sorties du contexte
c'est vrai que c'est le reproche qu'on
peut faire parfois ces vidéos on voit la
dernière scène où on a les policiers qui
frappe le manifestons ne voit pas tout
la scène tout le contexte qu'est ce que
vous répondez d'abord j'aimerais
répondre par rapport à un fait c'est
vous avez dit que les policiers ont peur
pour leur sécurité quand ils sont chez
eux et c'est moi j'aimerais juste vous
rappeler la ce visuel qui a été fait par
le syndicat alliance où justement il
montrer directement un journaliste à
boire
et c'est qu'enfin je comprends pas c'est
quoi c'est un appel il ya marqué que tu
as boivent sachent que notre collègue
n'est pas seul eq alliance police
nationale est à ses côtés
c'est moi j'ai l'impression que c'est
plus une menace en fait vous agissez en
tant que corps pour vous protéger et
qu'en est il de la liberté de la presse
voilà moi ça me questionne et moi j'ai
plus peur pour ce journaliste
d'ailleurs au moment où il est sorti
cette affiche un jour après je crois son
adresse a été publiée dans des réseaux
d'extrême droite sur facebook et a donc
moi c'est plus pour lui que j'ai peur en
ce moment plutôt que pour des policiers
qui d'ailleurs sont sans armée après
votre question c'était par rapport au
contexte
pour moi le contexte d'une vidéo
lorsqu'il a une violence qui est
flagrante en fait les les images parlent
en fait quand il ya des images qui
tournent beaucoup c'est que c'est
quelque chose qui même contextualiser
est extrêmement violent et
injustifiables en fait et pour moi en
fait c'est un faux argument c'est oui
mais ils l'ont bien cherché
c'est cette rhétorique elle est très
compliqué à défendre parce que la police
elle est là pour répondre à des
illégalismes elle est là pour répondre à
des situations de délits donc c'est pour
ça qu'on l'a créé et si tout le monde se
comportait bien il y aurait pas besoin
de police donc si la police existe c'est
uniquement pour répondre de manière
pacifié de manière proportionnée à ces
actes qui sont qui peuvent être violents
que ce soit en manifestations ou wired
ailleurs donc moi pour moi le
raisonnement à avoir c'est pas
il y à des violences policières
parce que il y à des actes qui ont été
violents juste avant c'est pas comme ça
qu'on doit poser les choses pour moi
c'est parce qu'il y à des actes violents
que la police ait créé et qu'elles
doivent répondre de manière réglementer
de manière carré et dans le cadre du
droit à ces illégalismes justement c'est
très intéressant ce que vous dites parce
que vous montrer une image mais oui on
défendra à chaque fois qu'il y aura des
personnages qui prôneront de la haine
anti fiq et notamment sur des espaces
médiatiques nous défendrons évidemment
les policiers ça que les choses
pourraient faire sursauter oui c'est
quelqu'un qui prenait très clairement la
haine anti-flic donc évidemment qu'on a
on a répondu quant à communiquer après
vous parliez de quelque chose de très
intéressant c'est le cas c'est le fait
que la non violence policière me
permettrai ils y ont déboîté l'épaule
cet article deux côtés il l'enveloppé
dans la voiture le la violence policière
d'abord ne veut rien dire parce que
celle usage de la force soit il est
légitime soit il ne l'est pas s'il ne
l'est pas
s'il ne l'est pas légitime et bien dans
ce cas là il fait l'objet de procédures
et il y à des sanctions et d'ailleurs je
le redis dans notre corporation il n'y a
pas deux il n'y a pas d'impunité
par contre vous parliez de l'usaj de la
france et vous disiez mais non on ne
doit pas répondre à de la violence mais
la riposte fait partie du cadre
règlementaire des policiers parce que
lorsqu'on jette un cocktail molotov ou
un triple défi no hope la tête des
policiers ils répondent
et effectivement dans le cadre du
maintien de l'ordre puisque c'est ce que
vous avez l'air de citer le match énorme
pour rétablir l'ordre public après les
sommations du rage
effectivement il peut y avoir des usages
de la force parce que il faut rétablir
l'ordre et qu' on ne peut pas laisser
les scènes d'insurrection et tout le
monde en conviendra que nous avons
vue notamment le premier le 8 décembre
et je trouve que dire que les policiers
réagissent alors qu'il n'y a pas
forcément de raison c'était pas vrai je
vais vous donner un exemple très concret
16 mars 2010 9 avenue des champs elysées
c'était quasiment l'insurrection sur
l'avenue des champs et puis à trois
kilomètres de là il y avait la manif
pour le climat 50000 personnes
pas une insulte pas un crachat et
évidemment il ne s'est rien passé
donc vous voyez le contexte est vraiment
très différent et c'est pour ça que je
dis que c'est présentement dans 90 ans
ait bahi justement sa nuit quoi ce que
vous dites ça dit que les policiers ils
interviennent dans un cadre
réglementaire et que lorsque une
manifestation lorsqu'une situation
dérape pas ce qu'on peut pas parler que
du maintien d'ordre est aussi parfois
des interpellations qui se passe pas
bien évidemment lorsqu'on commet un
outrage rébellion lorsqu on résiste on
attaque les policiers alors qu'ils font
leur travail
effectivement il y a une réponse des
policiers
bien sûr qu'il ya une réponse parfois
par usage de la force parfois par à
menottage un peu un peu fort mais c'est
le contexte c'est aussi le métier de
policier
et c'est bien pour ça que ça les expose
jeu relevé surtout par rapport à la
marge le climat qui était calme
une autre manifestation de l'autre côté
ça veut dire que il y aurait selon vous
en tout cas si je vous suis une forme de
provocation dans ses autres
manifestations
alors ce ne sont pas des provocations ce
sont des attaques en règle mais des
professionnels parce qu'il faut pas
mettre tout le monde doit mettre dans le
même panier c'est à dire que il y à des
personnes qui venaient légitimement
manifester et dg des jaunes mais ça il
n'y a pas de souci là-dessus par contre
il y avait des individus des ultras
radicaux peu importe droite gauche c'est
pas ça le sujet mais qui viennent et qui
sont des spécialistes du désordre
spécialiste du chaos
on en a vu certains s'organisent
évidemment à visage dissimulé c'est pour
ça que nous on était très contents
lorsque la loi anti-casseurs notamment
été promulguée on regrette qu'on nous
ait pas donné la peau la possibilité
de prononcer des arrêtés d'interdiction
notamment de manifester à l'encontre des
individus ultra violent parce qu on
aurait pu au moins les écarter et
assister peut-être à des manifestations
nettement plus calme
mohamed gueye vous les avez vu vous de
vos propres yeux justement vous dites
ces gens qui sont venus attaquer en
règle les policiers ou c'est quelque
chose que vous en tant que témoin de ces
manifestations vous contestez c'est pas
quelque chose que je conteste qu'il y
ait des dégradations des violences
pendant les manifestations mais cet
argumentaire en fait est très fortement
contredit par le mouvement des gilet
jaune qui au départ était un mouvement
pacifique en fait c'étaient des gens qui
sont venus marcher sur les
champs-elysées alors peut-être que
s'était pas déclarée mais ils n'étaient
pas venus en découdre directement et ils
ont subi directement c'était le 24
novembre j étais des tirs de l bd du
lacrymo on a tous l'image de cette
personne les bras comme ça écarte et qui
se prend un tir de la bd dans le ventre
il faisait rien
en on a vu énormément des gens qui ne
faisait rien ou qui étaient juste là en
tant que manifestants qui se prenaient
des coups et et ça montre qu'en fait
cette violence elle peut naître elle
peut naître parce que oui la semaine
d'après le 1er décembre
les gens ne sont pas venus avec le même
esprit il est à l'arc de triomphe les
dégradations du patrimoine national
l'arc de triomphe par des manifestants
vous l'avez vu ça aussi
oui exactement les gens sont venus avec
des certains avec des casques avec des
lunettes de protection avec des masques
parce que la semaine dernière il ne
connaissait pas le lacrymo il savait pas
ce que c'était et là ils s'en prennent
ils disent mais c'est pas possible que
ce qu'on a fait pour subir sa est la
violence et elle n'est de ça en fait
elle est créée c'est une réaction à un
comportement policier qui peut être
parfois disproportionnées et du bon sens
et les manifestants ont dégradé larmes
de triomphe parce que il avait subi des
violences une semaine avant c'est ça je
pense qu'il ya une colère collective qui
monte et qui a été vraiment vraiment
agrandi par les violences qui ont été
commises le 24 novembre la semaine
d'avant
c'est très intéressant de parler du 24
novembre parce que le 24 novembre
c'était le premier et dernier et vous
savez qui s'était le premier et dernier
c'était un policier parce que le
policier il avait pris notamment un
engin incendiaire et il n'a toujours pas
retrouvé d'ailleurs l'usagé de son oeil
alors voyez il faut essayer de faire
attention lorsqu'on essaye d'expliquer
notamment le cadre du maintien de
l'ordre
dire que les policiers ont été les
premiers à faire usage de la force des
caisses d'un crime aux gènes alors qu'il
ne se passait rien alors ça c'est tout
simplement ne pas dire la vérité parce
que si la manifestation où le
rassemblement qu'ils soient déclarés ou
pas les limites c'est pas le sujet même
si il y aurait beaucoup à dire
eh ben vous voyez les policiers il reste
aux abords de la manifestation ils
essaient de contrôler parfois d'empêcher
que des individus pénètrent dans le
périmètre avec notamment des armes parce
que ça aussi on l'a vu et il faut voir
les photos que du matériel qu'on a saisi
notamment à la fois sur des personnes
est à la fois dans des véhicules qui se
rendait sur la capitale donc d'où
l'intérêt de d'avoir ces contrôles
préventifs et de laisser la police faire
son travail sereinement mais je crois
que là on s'éloigne un peu du sujet de
filmer les policiers ou pas rémy on est
encore dans le débat
de la violence cesse confrontés à la
violence elle vous savez usage de la
force par les forces de sécurité elle
n'existe que s'il se passe quelque chose
s'il ne se passe rien les policiers
restent bien évidemment dans
l'encadrement strict de la manifestation
ou du rassemblant justement stanislas
voulons j'allais y revenir dans ce débat
selon des informations toujours reconnu
par mediapart un étude serait en cours
pour rendre obligatoire justement le
floutage des forces de l'ordre est ce
que c'est ça précisément que vous vous
demandez ça vous suffirait ce floutage
comprendre vraiment anonymes les
policiers l'anonymisation wii continue
finalement diffuser les vidéos vis que
cette droite tout à coup sûr qu'un
effectivement de diffuser sur internet
les images que l'on souhaite aujourd'hui
déjà protéger la personnalité du
policier se serait déjà un pas comme ça
se fait d'ailleurs pour certains
services un peu particulier au sein de
du ministère de l'intérieur
ne serait ce que pour protéger les
policiers puis leur famille je le redis
je crois que c'est important et je crois
que tout le monde le comprendra
et peut-être que ça mettrait aussi un
coup d'arrêt à giresse cet emballement
médiatique sur les réseaux sociaux où on
condamne un peu vite et parfois
l'histoire n'est pas tout à fait celle
qu'on raconte dans les réseaux sociaux
notamment et mohamed chaoui
je pense que la police se protègent déjà
assez l'organisent elle organise sa
protection notamment par la complaisance
des groupes de police par rapport au
fait d'afficher leur et rio ou pas
quand vous allez en manifestation je
sais pas si vous allez encore beaucoup
mais une très grande partie des
policiers n'ont pas leurs ergots
d'afficher ce qui l'est c'est un numéro
en fait c'est un numéro qu'ils sont
censés avoir au niveau de la poitrine
qui est leur identification en fait
qu'ils aient leur identification qui
nous permet en fait de savoir déjà
qu'ils sont policiers et de pouvoir
s'il y a des désactivez co2 pouvoir
justement retrouver ces policiers vous
parliez de la loi anti-casseurs tout à
l'heure beaucoup de policiers sont
cagoulés en manifestations sont cagoulés
sens et rio sans brassards de police ce
qui rend complètement impossible à la
police ou à l'igpn ou à tout ce que vous
voulez de les retrouver et donc de punir
donc vous moi vous parlez de du fait que
les policiers sont extrêmement puni
extrêmement voilà les chiffres nous
montrent tout le contraire par rapport
au moment des gels et jaune ait eu plus
de 400
400 plaintes déposées à l'igpn combien
de condamnations
c'est quasiment aucune alors là vous
oubliez de dire quelque chose c'est que
les policiers on est triple sanction
ils ont des sanctions judiciaires
administratives et les sanctions sur la
carrière donc dire que il n'y a pas de
sanction il y en a deux mille trente
parents c'est à peu près le chiffre d'un
point de vue administratif
alors après vous parlez du r et o alors
c'est très intéressant parce que le r et
o effectivement on peut pas le mettre
sur des unités de maintien de l'ordre
lourde puisque les gilets ne ne peuvent
pas être doté notamment des scratchs et
de toute façon avec les gilets tactiques
qu'ils ont et tout l'harnachement
notamment du matériel pour les armes de
force intermédiaire c'est très compliqué
c'est l'éducation oui oui d'accord mais
c'est sûrement mais après la version pal
à la charge de la preuve
non là parce que en plus des vies des
policiers qui sont un visage dissimulé
ils sont pas un visage dissimulé ils
sont avec parfois des sommes
effectivement surtout les masques la
clinique au contrôle le cren
lacrymogènes mais ça ça fait partie de
leur matériel d'équipement
les black blocks souvent alors le la
police est là pour répondre à des actes
illégaux
si la police commet elle même des actes
illégaux qui va répondre à ces actes là
c'est ça la question qu'on peut se poser
en fait n'en fait bon si vous voulez
défendre mais black dog c'est très bien
c'est ça c'est votre droit
je mets en tout cas ce que là vous êtes
en train d'expliquer que des policiers
ils sont quelques boulets comme les
black blocks et qui devrait subir les
mêmes conséquences que les policiers ne
sont pas fait le pas portés
ils ont passé la séance en fait vous
êtes dans dans la recherche en fait de
la preuve aidé l'accusation de manière
constante vis-à-vis des policiers mais
en fait est ce que vous savez ce qui se
passe dans un maintien d'ordre est ce
que vous savez que sur un parcours par
exemple de 3 km lorsque les policiers
interviennent à un endroit c'est qu'il
ya parfois des raisons parfois c'est
qu'il ya une rue adjacente parce que
vous avez un groupe à risque qui arrive
et que vous êtes obligé de séparer la
manifestation ça s'est produit notamment
il n'y a pas longtemps place de la
république vous n'avez pas la vision
notamment du cadre du maintien de
l'ordre puisque c'est visiblement le
sujet qui vous intéresse le plus
mais on peut en parler très longuement
le maintien de l'ordre moi j'ai fait
quinze ans de maintien d'ordre donc je
sais un peu comment ça se passe et je
sais à quel point les manifestations
aussi leur visage a changé parce que là
maintenant oui oui depuis veux-tu depuis
quelques années là on a des groupes à
risque qui s'organise et qui ne sont pas
là seulement pour casser une vitrine
seulement pour dégradé un véhicule
ils sont là pour organiser notamment les
attaques en règle vis-à-vis des forces
de sécurité et après ce que l'on oublie
de dire c'est que ces groupes très
spécialisés savent très bien utiliser
notamment les manifestants pacifiques
comme des boucliers et ce qui d'ailleurs
rend très complexe la tâche du maintien
de l'ordre et du rétablissement de
l'ordre public
parce qu'il faut arriver à séparer les
individus ultra violents notamment des
manifestants pacifiques c'est pour ça
que nous on leur dit lorsqu'il ya des
sommations
il faut absolument que les personnes qui
sont dans le périmètre
ces cartes et nous laisse faire c'est
comme ça parce que justement les blessés
je n'ai pas les chiffres en tête
effectivement mais voilà comprenez que
ça puisse choquer effectivement là la
population alors oui après on peut se
jeter au visage nombre de blessés non
années 2000 dans le cadre des 66
manifestation de gilet jaune
enfin qui étaient plus des attroupements
à certains moments mais si il y à de l'
usage de la force n'est pas
réglementaire ça fait l'objet des
sanctions il ya des collègues notamment
qui vont faire l'objet
notamment de passage au tribunal après
le temps médiatique n'est pas le temps
de l'enquète et heureusement que dans ce
pays on recueille tous les éléments pour
mettre en condamnation ou mètres plus
tôt et organiser la défense aussi des
policiers parce que ce sont aussi des
hommes comme les autres et ils ont le
droit aussi au respect de la présomption
d'innocence mais vous continuerez vous
allez sur les manifestations à filmer à
diffuser vos images alors je continuerai
à y aller je continuerai je l'espère là
je suis en arrêt maladie parce que je me
suis pris ceci dans la jambe une grenade
d'un morceau de grenade les violences
policières en tant qu' en tant que
photographe en tant que reporter on en
subit à toutes les manifestations
on nous empêche de filmer plusieurs fois
on m'a donné des coups parce que j'étais
en train de filmer justement des
violences plusieurs fois j'ai reçu des
tirs de grenade vers moi alors que nous
étions un groupe de journalistes qui ne
faisons rien de plus que de filmer
justement ces violences là et
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment ça la
question
la police
et les syndicats plus précisément savent
que le gouvernement ne peut rien faire
sans eux ne peut plus rien faire parce
qu'il ya énormément de contestation
sociale
donc il ne prendra pas de sanctions
fortes et il renoncera chaque décision
qui ira à l'encontre de la police et
c'est ça la réelle problématique qu'on
vit aujourd'hui c'est est ce qu'on peut
considérer qu'on est encore dans une
démocratie si même nous qui faisons de
l'image en manifestation en est empêché
aujourd'hui je peux pas travailler à
cause de violences que j'ai subie en
fait et on est beaucoup on était 24 à la
manifestation du 5 décembre en été
une quinzaine également aux
manifestations du 9 janvier du en
janvier ça commence à faire système ça
commence à être autant dans donc je vous
laisse le mot de la fin
oui je vous laisse vos propos sur la
théorie du complot vis-à-vis des
policiers après vous parler d'eux
c'est très content de nom mais bon ça
c'est concret s'accordent à caen c'est
très concret et puis et puis vous vous
évoquez notamment le encore une fois
l'usagé des armes de force intermédiaire
j'ose espérer que vous étiez bien sûr
identifié comme étant un agent de presse
puisque vous savez que ça c'est possible
georges par les agences de presse ils
ont la possibilité de se faire connaître
notamment auprès de la préfecture de
police puisque c'était le cas avait vu
j'imagine que ça se passait à paris il
est un cadre un puisque notamment depuis
la fameuse affaire benalla il y a la
possibilité notamment de participer et
de films et bien sûr sans prendre de
risques parce qu on a aussi cette
responsabilité là c'est de vous
préserver notamment des attaques
merci beaucoup à tous les deux en tout
cas mohamed leftah fait ça ni 16 go de
pêche train venu débattre et c'est la
fin de ce journal on se retrouve dans
quelques petites minutes pour 1 point
complet sur l'actualité
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]
ici on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
[Musique]
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit c'est qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
alors ce coup ci c'est interdit
d'interdire
[Musique]
mais vous
un bon sapeur c'est quelqu'un de ton
agressif mais je vous le dirai déjà à
paris sans prétention qu aujourd'hui
pouvait faire tous les kilomètres vous
devrez pas quelqu'un on entoure nous
sommes en plein mois de novembre à bien
comme ça
j'aime tous mes sauf l'anonymat
l'anonymat de se monter ce poids tu
viens de chez toi tu vas au boulot tu
reviens personne a dit monsieur madame
vous êtes et les gaulois la vie est
belle en couleurs pourquoi diable bleu
vous pour vous allez tous au noir bleu
marine j'ai dû nous c'est pas possible
ça sert à rien l'habille le sapeur fait
jouer à l'ebit son premier rôle qu'ils
pensent qu'ils ne devaient pas cessé
d'être un verte et de communication mais
la sape basse et 16 sur le vivre
ensemble via la bi
[Musique]
le nouveau ministre de la santé olivier
et veyran a donné cet après midi le coup
d'envoi devant les députés des débats
sur la réforme des retraites vantant une
ambition immense un texte dénoncé par
les oppositions qui critiquent également
le départ d'agnès busan qui avait
notamment la charge de ce dossier
c'est une première depuis huit ans
l'armée syrienne a mis la main sur les
dernières poches qui était détenu par
les djihadistes autour des lèvres le
président syrien bachar el-assad
s'engage à poursuivre l'offensive dans
le nord ouest du pays pour libérer
l'ultime grand bastion tenu par les
djihadistes et les rebelles
les navires déployés dans la zone à
l'est de la bibine décision de l'union
européenne à l'issue d'une réunion des
ministres des affaires étrangères afin
d'empêcher le trafic d'armes le chef de
la diplomatie italienne luigi di maio
précise que cette mission navale sera
arrêtée si elle provoque un afflux de
bateaux de migrants
[Musique]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue si vous nous
rejoignez en direct sur rt france après
10 jours en commission spéciale les
députés ont officiellement commencé à
débattre de la réforme des retraites
l'assemblée nationale dans une ambiance
électrique
on retrouve notre envoyé spécial vieux
marre aussi
rieumes un bon soir vous êtes donc au
coeur du palais bourbon vous avez suivi
les débuts le coup d'envoi de ces
discussions quel bilan pour cette
première séance
et bien en fait le bilan c'est un petit
peu richard ferrand qui peut le résumer
par une phrase vous aurez des heures des
jours et des nuits pour vous ébrouer
dans la démocratie c'est ainsi en tout
cas que richard ferrand donc le
président de l'assemblée nationale a
rappelé à l'ordre la france
insoumise qui exprimait déjà son
mécontentement alors que le nouveau
ministre de la santé
olivier viron venait à peine d'entamer
le premier des nombreux discours de
cette première séance de débat sur la
réforme des retraites est en effet c'est
une masse colossale qui attend les
députés ici à l'assemblée nationale
quarante mille deux cent soixante dix
sept amendements au total ont été
déposées en vue de l'examen de ce texte
c'est un record pour cette législature
mais l'obstruction parlementaire par
l'obstruction pardon oui et
parlementaires par voie d'amendement
n'est pas le seul outil de l'opposition
dès la fin d'ailleurs des discours
d'ouverture
plusieurs motions ont été examinés alors
pour commencer deux motion de rejet
préalable
l'une visant le projet de loi ordinaire
déposée par le parti communiste et
l'autre visant le projet de loi
organique puisque vous savez qu'il ya
deux projets de loi dans cette réforme
des retraites donc le projet de loi
organique est visée par une un rejet
préalable déposée par cette fois ci les
républicains les motion de rejet
préalable ce sont des procédures qui
permettent de faire reconnaître par
l'assemblée que une ou l'autre des
dispositions d'un texte sont
anticonstitutionnelles et donc
permettent d'annuler totalement les
débats il y a eu ensuite une motion
cette fois-ci référendaire alors la
motion référendaire lorsqu'elles sont
signés par 10% des députés permet bien
sûr adopté par l'assemblée nationale
permet de demander au président de la
république
deux ouvriers un référendum sur le sujet
débattu
alors comme vous l'imaginez bien aucune
de ces motions en réalité n'ont été
adoptée l'issue des votes ne faisait
même pas ne faisait aucun doute mais en
réalité tout ceci est une stratégie en
réalité de l'opposition d'abord gagner
du temps et ensuite fait avoir de
l'antenne faire parler d'eux et faire
parler d'eux mais c'est une stratégie
qui a le don d'agacer la majorité
écouter ces amendements étaient déclinés
sur les 16 députés de notre groupe mais
la totalité de ces amendements on peut
estimer à 800 amendements que l'on a
décliné effectivement sur des
amendements de fond qui détricote projet
de loi qui décortique projet de loi et
qui montre à quel point il est régressif
et le roi des conséquences terribles
terrible pour les retraités à partir du
moment où on hystérise on théâtralise le
débat par des amendements qui n'ont
aucun sens qu'ils sont des amendements
prétexte dont le seul but est d'allonger
et d'embourber le débat je pense que le
principal risque c'est que cette débat
de clarté ce débat démocratique soit
confisqué le trouve ça dommage
très forme on va faire baisser de futurs
pensionnés les jeunes d'au moins entre
10 et 20% leur pension de retraite c'est
considérable et quel est le moyen que
nous avons si ce n'est d'alerter
l'opinion et d'alerter les
parlementaires sur leurs responsabilités
il reste maintenant à savoir comment
vont se dérouler les débats le vote
final est en théorie prévue pour le 3
mars mais les députés n'ont clairement
pas le temps d'ici là d'examiner tous
les amendements je vous le répète plus
de 40 millions était déposée il ya donc
deux possibilités repousser la date de
ce vote et peut-être même au-delà des
élections municipales ou alors pour le
gouvernement invoqué le 49-3 c'est une
extrémité donc personne ne veut mais qui
pourtant est sur toutes les lèvres est
mme mercille marc aussi en direct de
l'assemblée nationale une journée
symbolique pour les opposants au projet
de loi elles se sont mobilisés dans la
capitale direction l'assemblée nationale
un dispositif important de forces de
l'ordre a été déployé parmi les
manifestants et les coquerelles de la
france sera soumise ou encore olivier
besancenot du npa
on est conscient que c'est pas l'intérêt
du parlement que les choses vont se
passer mais à l'extérieur et c'est pour
ça qu'on est venu simplement d'abord se
rappeler au bon souvenir de l'assemblée
nationale de leur député pour dire qu on
les oubliera pas et n'oubliera pas
qu'ils comptent voter quoi mais dire à
travers eux que à emmanuel macron que
nous va pas lâcher la faire avec le
mouvement druze mouvement de grève
demeure de manifestations mobilisations
il doit continuer ce sera la seule issue
pour gagner maintenant on est condamné à
à tous taper sur le même clou parce que
si on n'a pas tous sur le même coup on
n'y arrivera jamais donc que ça soit par
une manifestation nationale la
généralisation de la grève on a besoin
de replanter dans le décor le fait qu'on
n'est pas des rigolos et qu' on n'a pas
fait tout ce qu'on a fait depuis le 5
décembre simplement pour gagner la
bataille des idées
aulas l'ambiance dans l'hémicycle c'est
toujours la même chose hier on a des des
ministres qui nous font du discours à la
orwell en permanence d'accord qui nous
explique ce serait une loi de protection
sociale de justice sociale certains ont
même acquis au même parler de démocratie
sociale c'est ça qui est le plus
insupportable
ils sont en train de démanteler un des
piliers du patrimoine social français et
ils font mine de quelque part vouloir en
réalité du progrès alors qu'ils ne font
que reculer l'âge de leur départ après
tu attaques et les pensions sans aucune
légitimité
donc je vais vous dire je pense que dans
l'assemblée ça va ça va être assez chaud
pendant plusieurs semaines et des
opposants si immobilisé depuis tôt ce
matin une cinquantaine de personnes se
sont ainsi retrouvées devant un site
ratp à saint denis pour un piquet de
grève certains d'entre eux étaient
présents dès 4 heures du matin les
manifestants ont réaffirmé leur soutien
au mouvement de contestation contre la
réforme
on voulait quand même marquer le coup
aujourd'hui sur cette journée du 17 pour
dire qu'à la ratp voilà on reste
mobilisés contre cette saleté de
réformes quoi tout simplement
aujourd'hui c'est une journée symbolique
voit la première première lecture à
l'assemblée on est encore là voilà et
puis
demain sénat-assemblée tout ce qu'on
veut on sera encore là journal officiel
on sera encore là et la réforme il a
retiré bas c'est le message il est clair
on est sur le terrain au quotidien avec
les collègues même si on a repris le
boulot et qu'on fait seulement les
grosses dates maintenant est en
discussions avec les collègues ils sont
toujours mobilisés et puis quand il ya
des dates des dates qui tombe comme ça
des journées importantes
[Musique]
ils sont là et nous à pleyel au centre
bus de pleyel en ait décidé de marquer
coûts et d'être là le 17 et selon axel
sabban avocat fiscaliste à paris le
timing risque d'être un peu juste pour
une adoption en première lecture de
cette réforme des retraites
il ya quarante et un mille amendements
qui ont été déposés dans le cadre de cet
examen en séance
ça me paraît très compliqué de tenir les
délais du gouvernement qui est l'idée de
mémoire sont fixées au 3 mars pour pour
l'adoption en première lecture
sauf si les députés décident d'avoir des
journées je ne sais pas où ils vont
trouver les heures nécessaires à
l'examen de tous ses amendements et du
texte en général on a une ministre qui
part faire des municipales à paris donc
qui n'est absolument pas préparé pour
cette cet enjeu des municipales mais
quel est le message que cela envoie au
fond c'est qu'un ministre peut être
parfaitement remplacé sur des sujets
extrêmement technique qui soulève
énormément de grogne parmi nos citoyens
mais en fait est-ce que ce ministre là
est vraiment porteur d'un message
personnel d'une d'une touche personnelle
sur les réformes
ou alors c'est juste un produit
politique qui remplaçables à volonté car
de toute façon les orientations
techniques sont décidés autres parents
on peut se poser la question de la
pertinence de l'identité du ministre de
la santé en fait aujourd'hui si on peut
remplacer n'importe quelle politique
d'un claquement de doigts c'est beaucoup
trop facile et ça permet de justifier
largement la colère de personnes qui
sont placés sous la tutelle de ce
ministère il venait d'être nommé
rapporteur du volet organique de la
réforme des retraites
olivier verrey on prend la casquette de
ministre de la santé à la passation de
pouvoir s'est déroulée ce matin avec
agnès buzyn semer
or jusque-là d'écouter la république en
marge de 10 heures occupée depuis deux
ans et demi le poste de rapporteur
général de la commission des affaires
sociales et nièces busan donc
démissionné hier de ses fonctions pour
se lancer dans la bataille des
municipales en remplacement de benjamin
griveaux à paris
mesdames et messieurs c'est avec une
grande émotion que je quitte de résister
le résultat avec les la cité pour mener
la campagne des élections municipales à
paris
j'ai remis hier soir ma démission au
premier ministre et au président de la
république quitte et sonny liston vous
l'imaginez c'est un déchirement
pendant plus de deux ans et demi j'ai
l'honneur de conduire des politiques de
santé et les politiques que le social de
l'entreprise
quel bilan agnès buzyn lestel au
ministère de la santé la réponse de
gérald kirneck médecin urgentiste
on a été touché il ya deux ans quand
elle a pris deux ans et demi quand elle
a pris ministère de la santé on s'est
dit tiens médecin hospitalière qui
connaît bien ce côté sincérité comme ça
spontanée le problème c'est que depuis
deux ans et demi c'est une catastrophe
le bilan politique du ministère de la
santé depuis deux ans et demi ce sont
des hôpitaux qui sont grève des services
d'urgence qui sont en grève depuis 11
mois ce sont des plans comme ma santé
2022 qui ne répondent à aucune attente
ni de la population ni des médecins
généralistes
l'idée hospitalier mille démission de
chef de service ya à peine un mois bref
on voit bien que depuis deux ans et demi
la situation n'a fait que s'aggraver
dans le bios politique est un mauvais
bilan politique on parle la crise du
coronavirus voilà il n'y a pas eu crise
du corps d'un virus parce qu'il n'ya pas
que coronavirus autrui et pas de
dangerosité
à date de ce virus sinon je pense qu'on
aurait été très très mal pour pouvoir le
gérer
en tout cas nous on va pas le regretter
et on va pas regretter non plus la
surdité qu'on avait au ministère de la
santé tous les syndicats sont deux
d'accord commun pour dire il n'y avait
pas d' écoutes qui avait pas de dialogue
donc je sais pas comment ça va se passer
sur une campagne municipale mais en tout
cas il n'y avait pas de dialogue au
ministère et les ai vu un qui donc ses
fonctions en pleine crise du coronavirus
le nombre quotidien de décès est en
baisse pour la troisième jeu
des consécutive à l'organisation
mondiale de la santé elle aimait des
réserves ont fait le point avec leïla
sarraf
en dehors de la chine continentale des
malades dans une trentaine de pays du
monde
un ralentissement du nombre quotidien de
dessin a notamment été notifié si ce
dernier bilan semble confirmer une
décrue l'organisation mondiale de la
santé a lancé un appel à la paix il est
impossible de prévoir quelles directions
l'épidémie prendra nous demandons à tous
les gouvernements toutes les sociétés et
tous les organismes de presse de
travailler avec nous pour déclencher le
niveau d'alarmé idoine sans souffler sur
les braises de l'hystérie l'épidémie
maintien
coopération la chine à solide système de
santé publique
la chine a un solide système
scientifique et de découverte
la chine a la capacité de développer
d'augmenter la production de vaccins
travailler avec la chine
des experts internationaux dépêchés à
pékin par l' oms ont commencé à étudier
l'épidémie du nouveau coronavirus covit
19 avec leurs homologues chinois
une collaboration dont le monde entier
espèrent qu'elle portera ses fruits
rapidement et pour jennifer nonso
épinière moniot épidémiologistes
chercheuse au centre de sécurité
sanitaire de l'université johns hopkins
avoir un leader durant cette période de
crise reste primordial on écoute un
changement de direction
en période de crise ce n'est pas idéal
et j'espère qu'il y à des fonctionnaires
qui sont présents pour continuer ce
travail c'est vraiment essentiel c'est
là que se trouve l expertise technique
avoir une personnalité forte et
respectée afin de diriger et d'être le
visage public de la réaction c'est très
important
j'étais nationale et son nationale sont
essentielles c'est elle qui vont assurer
le travail au niveau des communautés
l'om est bien sûr est une ressource
importante mais il s'agit notamment d'un
organisme ne sera pas au coeur des
opérations notamment dans ce cas de
figure où il ya des jeux problème c'est
traité dans le monde entier n'ont pas
les ressources suffisantes autorités de
santé nationales et locales à la
passeront donc en première ligne
c'est une première depuis huit ans
l'armée syrienne a mis la main sur les
dernières poches qui était détenu par
les djihadistes autour d'alep
selon l'agencé sana les combattants
auraient quitté leur avant poste à
l'ouest et au nord de la ville direction
la frontière turque
les précisions de rania berrada ce
n'était pas arrivé depuis 2012 l'armée
syrienne vient de reprendre le contrôle
de 28 poche jusque-là aux mains des
groupes islamistes en banlieue d'alep
annonce de l'agencé de presse publique
syrienne sana
dans une allocution le porte parole de
l'armée syrienne s'est félicité du
succès de l'opération
les héros de l'armée arabe syrienne ont
poursuivi leur avancée
déterminé à déraciner le terrorisme des
mécréants et à chasser les tueurs armés
qui voulaient confisquer la volonté de
notre peuple dans la région il les
prenait en otage et les utiliser comme
des boucliers humains afin d'entraver
l'avancée de l'armée et de retarder la
fin de ces factions armées qui sont des
factions terroristes selon le droit
international
nos braves soldats ont un conflit leur
mission avec une grande efficacité et en
un temps record des dizaines de villages
et de villes sont de nouveau sous le
contrôle du gouvernement
à l'ouest et au nord-ouest dallest
[Musique]
toujours selon l'agencé sana les
combattants djihadistes se sont retirés
de leurs avants postes vers la frontière
turque
il laisse ainsi la totalité de la
périphérie d'alep au monde des forces de
bachar el-assad une route stratégique
reliant damas et alep avec ses centres
industriels a également été reprise aux
rebelles dimanche soir à l'annoncé de ce
succès militaires des scènes de liesse
ont éclaté dans la ville les habitants
d'alep se disent soulagés du départ des
groupes jihadistes c'est grâce à dieu
grâce à nos prières
grâce à l'armée arabe syrienne que dieu
les protège et face qu'ils retrouvent
leur famille vous êtes la meilleure
armée du monde
vous avez mis à genoux les états unis
vous avez mis à genoux les turcs et tous
les envahisseurs et nous sommes fiers de
vous vous êtes la syrie vous avez appris
au monde le sens du mot liberté
le président syrien bachar al assad
s'est engagé ce lundi à poursuivre
l'offensive dans le nord-ouest du pays
pour libérer l'ultime grand bastion tenu
par les djihadistes une déclaration qui
intervient alors que l'onu réitère ses
appels pour un cessez-le-feu dans la
région d'idlib
selon les nations unies dans cette zone
les combats et frappes aériennes ont
fait plus de 900 mille déplacés depuis
décembre et pour adlène mohammedi
chercheur en géopolitique la progression
de l'armée loyaliste devrait subir un
coup d'arrêt le nord ouest aujourd'hui
est l'ultime poche rebelle l'ultime page
jihadistes pour le l'ultime page de
djihadistes qui résistent encore à la
reconquête uriel c'est alors la
rencontre loyalistes est menée par d'un
côté l'armée syrienne et de l'autre par
l'armée russe qui a soutenu largement
cette reconquête notamment sur le plan
aérien je pense qu'il faudra encore
attendre la l'armée syrienne a bien
avancé dans la région d'alep
il y a une dizaine de jours l'armée
syrienne a fait une avancée majeure dans
la province d'idleb
je pense notamment à une ville qui
faisait la jonction entre les deux
principales art
les deux principales routes de la région
les autoroutes cannes 4e 5
l'un je pense qu'ils sont en train de se
calmer il est si on réfléchit un peu à
cette scion si on repense un peu ou pas
ces deux sets avant cette offensive
loyalistes dans la région
on se rend compte que elle se fait par à
coups ces terres que la russie veille au
grain elle ne veut pas d'une offensive
loyalistes total tout simplement parce
que la turquie
brandy brandit sa ligne rouge et donc je
pense que là il ya en ce moment des
négociations entre la russie et la
turquie justement août au sujet d'idleb
je pense qu'il y avait dans les
prochaines semaines il va y avoir un
petit ralentissement des dauphins du
royaliste l union européenne est
parvenue à un accord pour déployer des
navires de guerre à l'est de la libye
afin d'empêcher les livraisons d'armes
dans le pays la fin d'un embargo qui a
longtemps fait débat au sein des états
membres les explications avec florian
lambert un embargo qui divise l'europe
l'union européenne n'est pas en mesure
d'aboutir à un accord pour reprendre
l'opération navale sofia dont le mandat
arrive à terme le mois prochain
une opération initiée en 2015 et qui a
pour but de contrôler les flux
migratoires et les causes des trafics
humains en méditerranée le chef de la
diplomatie européenne josep borrell a
tenu à rappeler l'urgence d'un accord
sous l'embargo de l'onu sur les armes à
destination de la libye auxquels sofia
contribue depuis 2016 cet embargo
affaibli l'économie de ce pays
ils perdent 60 millions de dollars par
jour à cause d'un pétrole qu'ils ne
peuvent pas vendre
vous imaginez le montant de toute l'aide
européenne est de 600 millions d'euros
l'équivalent de dix jours où vous coupez
le pétrole autre volet de l'opération
sofia l'entraînement des garde côtes
libyens depuis l'été 2010 8 ils sont
chargés par l'europe de coordonner les
sauvetages de réfugiés une mission que
la libye en guerre est incapable de
mener à bien
selon les ong
le commandant veux préciser qu'il y a eu
90 morts lorsque nous étions au large
près de la côte de garat bulli à l'est
de tripoli en libye
et qu'il n'y avait pas de bateau pour
les sauver de son côté l'autriche voit
dans l'opération sofia un billet
d'entrée en europe pour des milliers de
migrants clandestins et refuse donc de
donner son accord
une situation de blocage pour l'action
européenne à laquelle le chef de la
diplomatie allemande n'a pas tardé à
réagir
ceux qui pensent avant tout aux
questions de migrations doivent être
conscients que les problèmes de
migration ne peuvent être résolus que si
la libye ne démord pas un état en
faillite
le mandat de sofia était prolongé
jusqu'au 31 mars 2020 mais son activité
n'est plus opérationnel faute d'accord
les états membres ont retiré leur navire
pour prendre en charge la migrants
sauvés en mer mais l'autriche n'est pas
le seul pays à bloquer et si le
désaccord se poursuit
le dossier sera reportée à la prochaine
réunion des ministres européens des
affaires étrangères prévue le 23 mars
pour claude un blanchemaison expert en
relations internationales le consensus
de l'union européenne relève du miracle
c'est un petit peu un miracle parce que
les pays de l'union européenne était
très divisée c'est probablement un
succès personnel pour josette borel
le représentant de l'union européenne
pour la politique extérieure et de
sécurité puisqu'il a habilement négocié
pour aboutir à un consensus
alors on a vu que c'était un début
difficile du côté italien du côté
autrichien puisque les tchadiens avaient
très peur d'une augmentation des
réfugiés puisque si on crée une nouvelle
force militaire c'est-à-dire que des des
navires militaires mis à disposition par
les états membres de l'union européenne
volontairement vont patrouiller dans la
partie est de la de la côte de la côte
de la libye et avec pour but d'empêcher
d'intercepter les trafics d'armes
évidemment si il y à des réfugiés sur un
récif en danger est la loi
internationale oblige en principe à leur
porter secours
et c'est ce que voulait éviter les
italiens
donc les italiens ont deux clauses de
sauvegarde qui est une
si ça se produisait si on les admire les
ports italiens et bien là le la sphère
s'arrêterait là
c'est à dire que la force n'existerait
plus et puis comme moyen terme les
italiens dit si c'est un bateau allemand
qui prend les réfugiés et bien elle a
qu'a les amener en allemagne très
direction la syrie où le président du
parlement reçu hier son homologue
iranien à damas au cours de cette
rencontre les deux parties sont
longuement revenu sur la situation de
crise en syrie
iranien ali larijani a salué les
relations entre son pays et damas les
qualifiant de dernier axe résistant le
plus important il a également réaffirmé
la nécessité de l'implication
internationale afin de trouver une
solution de sortie crise est toujours
concernant l'iran hassan un roi ni ne
démissionnera pas le président iranien
fait cette annonce hier pour mettre fin
aux rumeurs en vue des législatives du
21 février à san juan qui a promis
d'aller jusqu'au bout de son mandat qui
s'achève en 2021 ma démission ne ferait
pas vraiment sens
nous avons fait des promesses auprès du
peuple
et nous continuerons à les remplir
en dépit de la situation économique et
de la pression de l'ennemi
je ne laisserai même pas le gouvernement
quitter ses responsabilités une heure
plus tôt à moi ou une semaine plus tôt
la direction présents le yémen les
belligérants sont parvenus hier à un
accord historique un premier échange de
prisonniers d'envergure depuis 2014 le
gouvernement reconnu par la communauté
internationale
appuyé par une coalition militaire sous
commandement saoudien s'affrontent avec
les rebelles houthi soutenu par l'iran
cet accord est un signe d'espoir pour le
nu qui qualifie la situation de pires
crises humanitaires au monde david kelly
faim des prisonniers sourire aux lèvres
accueillis par les autorités et leurs
familles après leur libération
des images que l'onu veut voir se
répéter pour mettre fin à cinquante
conflit avec cet accord d'échangé de
prisonniers conclu ce dimanche entre les
parties et millau et mène un nouveau pas
vers la paix a été réalisée il s'agit
d'une étape vers la réalisation de
l'engagement des parties à libérer
progressivement tous les détenus liés au
conflit conformément à l'accord de
stockholm
le nombre de prisonniers concernés n'est
pas mentionnée mais les rebelles ont
fait état de 1400 détenus appelés être
libéré une avancée considérable
au vu du climat tendu ces derniers jours
un nouveau raid aérien de la coalition
militaire a fait au moins 31 morts et 12
blessés ce samedi au lendemain du crash
d'un avion de combat saoudiens engagés
dans la guerre contre les rebelles dans
ce pays
pourtant le même jour le ministre des
affaires étrangères d'arabie saoudite
s'est dit plein d'espoir sur une
possible entente entre le gouvernement
et les outils comme je les dis nous
sommes là pour soutenir le gouvernement
du yémen dont toute paix viendra d'un
accord entre le mouvement outils et le
gouvernement du yémen suis-je plus
optimiste maintenant je ne dirais pas
que je suis nécessairement optimiste
mais je suis plein d'espoir et nous
allons faire tout notre possible pour
atteindre 2,7
objectif je pense qu'il ya des progrès
nous avons eu une certaine détérioration
récemment mais nous sommes déterminés à
progresser
cependant s'il ya une provocation sur le
terrain nous devrons bien sûr y répondre
mais nous travaillons très très dur pour
trouver un moyen d'avancer avancé pour
faire cesser cette crise sans fin depuis
2014 le conflit au yémen oppose le
gouvernement reconnu par la communauté
internationale
appuyé par une coalition militaire sous
commandement saoudien aux rebelles
houthi soutenu par l'iran
une situation critique qui oblige les
yéménites à quitter leur pays pour
pouvoir accéder aux soins médicaux
la femme a été diagnostiqué avec un
cancer
vous ne pouvez pas faire de scanner ou
de radiothérapie au yémen nous
attendions pour partir de sanaa mais la
ville est assiégée
l'aéroport est fermé nous ne pouvions
pas voyager à cause de la guerre et la
crise il n'y a pas de médecin on ne peut
pas faire de radiothérapie et c'est
impossible d'importer de l'équipement
avec le siège nous n'avons pas de
traitement nous manquons de tout la
guerre au yémen a fait des dizaines de
milliers de morts essentiellement des
civils selon plusieurs organisations
humanitaires
autres chiffres plus de 24 millions de
yéménites soit plus de 80% de la
population ont besoin d'assistance
c'est ce qu'estime l'onu qui qualifie la
situation de pires crises humanitaires
au monde et pour benoît un mur atcher
président de lo ng action sécurité
éthique républicaine cet accord ne
résout pas la question de la guerre
aucun moment
martin ruetschi tu communiques en disant
que les pourparlers entre les
différentes parties au conflit parce
qu'elles sont nombreuses et bien avancé
et qu' il y aurait une baisse de la
violence sur le terrain pour les
populations civiles
le rapport du pnue d' donc le programme
des nations unies pour le développement
avec une projection de plus de 240 mille
morts
à la fin de 2019 dans plus de 140 mille
enfants morts directs et indirects
donc nous sommes toujours dans une fille
chiffres extrêmement graves et il n'y a
toujours pas de d'engagement du conseil
de sécurité où les cinq membres du
conseil de sécurité
que ce soit les français les etats-unis
1-1 ou à la grande-bretagne qui continue
de fournir des armes
donc on dit qu'on veut faire la paix
mais en continu de fournir des armes et
ses armes servent donc les premiers pas
pour nous qui serons un véritablement
des signe de désescalade de la violence
sur place seront les moments où les deux
pays ou qui sont partis du traité sur le
commerce des armes respecteront son
article 6 qui de dit qu ils doivent
cesser toute exportation d'armes en
direction des pays de la coalition et
les états unis qui ont signé qui doivent
normalement respectés en tout cas les
objectifs du traité arrêter la
souffrance des yéménites
bref c'est la fin de cette édition merci
de l'avoir suivi prochain journal demain
matin à 7 heures du matin heure
française
[Musique]
aussi on écoute ceux qui ne sont pas
d'accord
ici qu'on invite les plus compétents pas
seulement ceux qui parlent le plus fort
[Musique]
ici on reçoit ce qu'on ne voit pas
ailleurs
[Musique]
parce qu'ici c'est interdit d'interdire